[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show
and my guest today is the one and only
apology s srinivasan you can find him on
twitter at biology s
biology is an angel investor and
entrepreneur he has the first and second
place records for longest podcast
episodes ever on this podcast we will
probably keep it to two and a half to
three hours i say with great confidence
now formally this people listen to them
they do they do people listen to them
they did a lot of people the last two
appearances were two of the most popular
episodes
certainly in the last year to 18 months
formerly the cto of coinbase and general
partner at andreessen horowitz he was
also the co-founder of earn.com acquired
by coinbase council acquired by myriad
teleport acquired by topia and coin
center he was named to the mit
technology reviews innovators under 35
won a wall street journal innovation
award and holds a bs ms phd in
electrical engineering and an ms and
chemical engineering all from stanford
university biology also teaches the
occasional class at stanford in his
spare time including an online mooc in
2013 which reached 250 000 plus students
worldwide his brand new book is the
network state how to start a new country
and we will certainly wade into those
waters and explore
all of the related topics in depth but
let us begin if we can biology with the
current state of the crypto market i
know a lot of people would love to hear
your thoughts on what you're observing
and just to date this we are recording
july 1
2022 and then perhaps hearing your
thoughts on the india sphere but let's
begin with those two prompts
sure so i'm not a
trader like uh you know i'm more of a
much more of a long-term investor slash
angel slash vc there's actually a
there's a fun tweet today by a guy
travis underscore cling i've been doing
this for 46 straight months i've never
seen one like this before and he's just
got a list of all the carnage in the
markets and the thing is that carnage is
in the crypto markets but it's also in
the in the non-crypto markets
and it is it's a little more pronounced
in crypto but it is definitely like a
systemic type of thing and the way i
kind of think about it is there's very
few spaces that i get into
where i don't have an all-weather thesis
that works independent of the price
and so i was in genomics way before like
people were talking about genomics i was
you know doing machine learning way
before people were talking about
machining you know like it's kind of
weird
to see people talking about stuff that
you're doing like 10 or 15 or whatever
years ago not to say in a thumb chest
way but just that
you want to try to identify these things
that have value independent of that and
the fundamental value of cryptocurrency
is
can you have a system
where the root permissions are
independent of the us and chinese
establishments
that is the fundamental question is one
of digital freedom because and i can
kind of tease that out and and so on and
so forth but it's fundamentally do you
actually have
property rights on the internet digital
property rights or can somebody with a
police badge
from the us or chinese establishment
depending on what side of the world
you're on
get into all of your stuff surveil all
of your stuff take all of your stuff
freeze and seize all of your stuff and
so on and so forth right so that
fundamental question of whether digital
property rights
should exist and whether they will be
valuable in the medium to long term is
what gives me confidence in the space
not the specific price
so i can talk more but that's you know
prices down prices up i would only
invest in those kinds of things that i
believe further that aspect of like
freedom and control
question for you in our first episode i
think at some point
you mentioned
for someone who is not going to make a
full-time study of things
splitting their allocation to crypto and
this is not investment advice this is
two people talking for informational
purposes only but splitting 50 50
bitcoin eth does that still hold or
would you based on
what you've seen since and what you are
seeing now
maybe any developing theses change that
no i i'd say stick with that i mean
again not investment advice and so on
but basically
those ecosystems are just still
absolutely massive if you look at
as i said you know i i think i said
something like
buy it and then hold it for 10 years
let's see where we are in 10 years the
fundamentals in terms of not not just
number of users but
conversation i mean if you could if
twitter was open source or rather more
specifically if it was open state let's
say not just the source code was
available but the backend was available
the database was available okay not just
through an api but that you could just
hit a key and see every tweet if you
wanted to every public tweet at least if
it was open state and you could plot
the number and the depth of interactions
on bitcoin and ethereum and all of their
offshoots not just those keywords but
the
thousands of keywords and memes and
communities and so on that would be
built on this these are like countries
that have built out
and you know like
those are things that just have mass to
them and you can mark them to market
they've got downs and they've got ups
but they are absolutely massive things
with tens of millions of dedicated
people around the world
and they come out of nowhere so yeah i
don't believe that they're gonna go away
but again not financial advice it's just
my personal personal belief you can get
much more sophisticated than that but
like the absolute worst thing to do by
the way and this is maybe obvious but
i'll just say this is
the worst thing to do is buy an asset
when it's in the news and sell it when
it's in the news
and what you instead want to kind of do
is
like something it's all inevitable that
something will pique your attention okay
and then what you do is you set a
calendar reminder you know let's say 30
days 60 days 90 days
so that you are almost like retargeting
yourself
and then you go and you actually do
research on it outside of the scrum
right outside of people yelling about it
you intentionally do it async to the
market sentiment this famous cartoon
it's a guy he's like this looks like it
could be a good buy and someone over
here is they're like bye bye bye bye bye
and then the guy's like this doc could
really excel and someone over here sell
so sell sell you know like this right
and it's this hilarious sort of loop
which you don't want to be the current
thing you're on you don't want to be the
person who is
buying high selling low and i think the
only way to not do that is set calendar
reminders assess your portfolio like
whether it's a quarterly basis or
something like that and try to make
async decisions
like you almost never want to sell on
bad news buy on good news that's my
macro outside of any given you know
specific thing yeah let me add one thing
to that which is
humans in general and i succumb to this
sometimes to over
estimate their predictive abilities so
what is very helpful is set a time it
could be once a year jan 1
jan five doesn't really matter
where you sit down and you identify say
i'm just picking a time frame six months
from now and you grab a bunch of
potential
asset classes or stocks or indices so
maybe it's
bitcoin
a barrel of oil
s p 500
and make your predictions and then set a
reminder to look at them
three months or six months later when
you may
as you are influenced subconsciously by
chatter on twitter
trends in
the news and so on to think that you
know where things are going let's see
how successful you were over the
preceding six months so that's also a
good way to check your cognitive biases
can i talk about that for a second the
predictability involved yes you got okay
so this is something i actually write
about in the book which is we're sort of
re-entering high volatility times
and
the thing about this is most people
don't think about it this way but
companies and governments
shield people from volatility
to an extent that we don't really think
about that much and now that shielding
is going away for example when you go
and
buy like a laptop from apple and they
quote you some price let's say i don't
know what it is
1499 or 99 i don't know what the number
is okay i'm just making that up when
they quote you that price
that includes that's a price that they
are
you know selling it for but the price of
aluminum is bouncing around the price of
you know their rare earth elements on
the back end that's bouncing around
their cost of goods
is if they weren't if they were just
buying at spot prices bouncing around
every day and so in theory their margin
could shrink or grow or whatever on on a
given day now what do they do to deal
with this they buy in bulk they have
various futures contracts and so on they
buy and sell collars so they give up
some of the upside on that margin to
bound their downside they're getting
aluminum for x dollars per kilogram as
opposed to greater than x or lower than
x so those companies actually buffer all
kinds of crazy variations to give you
that clean dependable
99 or 29 or 1499 whatever price okay
and governments do this as well in lots
of other ways
you know that's why you don't have
people walking down the streets with aks
that's why you you don't have mobs
pillaging and so on and so forth right
wait wait hold on cue tie those two
things together so i followed you on the
futures contracts and maybe you know if
they're dealing with currency certainly
they would have other protections in
place but how do we go from that to
preventing people from walking around
with aks sure sure so i believe there's
a connection i just would love for you
to elaborate
absolutely so it's social and financial
volatility
and the way i think about that so let's
start with financial because it's more
it's a little more quantitative and
people know about right
there's this concept called market depth
and if you've ever looked at
like coinbase pro or any crypto exchange
you see this like v like thing with the
the buy orders on one side sell orders
on this side and this is like uh you
know how a price is born normally
you know most people in normal life are
price takers you go to the store and you
buy orange juice for whatever the price
is now 50 bucks or
something i don't know what it is today
but you know what i'm saying right okay
a gallon of orange juice is i don't know
some price okay and
you're a price taker it's set price 4.99
or something like that
the thing is if you start emptying out
the shelves if you buy a hundred units
of orange juice and then you go to the
next door it might be 550. and then the
third store hears you're coming and they
set it to seven bucks and so on and so
forth right you start moving the market
price you are now a price setter in a
sense when you start clearing out units
so you've got 100 units at 499 and then
200 units at 550 and now you can get 300
units at seven and your supply
increases as the price increases and
then conversely on the other side right
and so that is actually how a price is
born it's most people don't usually
think about this because you're buying
like single individual consumer units
you're not like a
a bulk purchaser but when you're
purchasing in bulk suddenly people are
negotiable you know they can they can
make more money on it they're okay with
negotiating okay what's my point this
idea of market depth just like we see
like a price shift back and forth you
know with sentiment that's the same
concept in financial terms as the
overton window the overtone window is
the set of what things are politically
acceptable and sentiment shifts back and
forth there's a thing here's the current
center and as radicals you know push
that thing that was totally unthinkable
moves to the center or conversely
conservatives push and and suddenly it
gets pushed back right that's kind of
like buy and sell pressure in fact you
can think of it a lot like that on any
given issue and
you have essentially almost like votes
right like
you have a 1 000 votes for this level of
the policy and
5 000 votes for this level of policy and
10 000 votes for this level policy and
then you know you have you have some on
the other side and when you can shift
over those vote banks you shift that
midpoint which is a policy just like if
you can shift over the order book you
shift over the price okay yeah that's
clever right okay
that is the macro of how i think about
like prices and policies you know when
people say oh that's getting political
what they're really talking about is
just like with the price example most
people are price takers okay
you know as i said you go and buy the
orange juice
just like most people are law takers
okay the law the policy is just applied
to you you know but if somebody is like
powerful enough or it's like a weird
enough situation that law flexes
okay concrete example
singapore you know a couple i'm taking
an example that's like out of our time
and place you know and so on so people
don't get mad singapore like two and a
half decades ago i think in 1987 there
was an american citizen michael fay who
was vandalizing things in singapore okay
i remember this and
you remember this right and singapore
was going to cane him as per singapore
law and frankly had he been a
singaporean or he had been anybody other
than an american he would have been a
law taker
okay the law would have just been
applied
but
all kinds of pressure got applied
on this side of the policy
market
and lee kuan yew was like okay we're
gonna like reduce the number of strokes
of the cane he didn't set it to zero
because that would have been too much of
a give but as a consideration for the
like the u.s government made it like a
diplomatic situation and like the
president got involved and all the stuff
they're telling in singapore so the
pressure for singapore was significant
on the policy side and so now there was
it was the law was negotiable right
that's what it means for something to
quote get political
is that you have huge masses of people
that assemble and they shift the
midpoint of the overton window just like
huge massive people shift the midpoint
of a price
right now the thing is as i mentioned
earlier with twitter that back end is
not open state
so because it's not open state we cannot
see
sentiment moving
as we can with price not as easily not
as easily go ahead yeah i was just going
to say there there are other tools that
i also
you probably don't know this but i i pay
a good amount of attention to this type
of thing on a number of fronts so google
trends i mean they're not open state
exactly but you can track
certain types of sentiment or interest
or fear yes longitudinally but continue
i didn't mean to interrupt no no you're
right in one sense we've got far more
information than we ever had in another
sense i know we have a hundred or a
thousand x left to go
and the reason is that
think about the difference between
and this is a tech analogy so you might
be like
well think about it huh okay but think
about the difference between at t unix
and linux okay
so if you're an engineer you're like
yeah dude
att unix was was good but it wasn't
hackable i couldn't customize it i
couldn't take it apart look at the
engine block i couldn't make it work on
tiny devices and giant servers i
couldn't make it mine right and so
currently it's good yes that we have
google trends that we have you know the
like you can kind of get some sense from
the twitter api and so on but they're
very locked down in a certain way where
there's queries you can't easily run you
might have to pay a lot for the api and
so it's over versus if that data set was
open we'd have completely different
understanding of society and history and
politics it would be at the same level
as the unlock going from
at t units to linux or the unlock of
going from like paypal to bitcoin
so let me jump in because the next
question i want to ask
is what some of the
to you most foreseeable technological
developments are that you say almost
treat as assumptions
in building out your vision for the
future over the next x years and you can
choose x and this might be a place also
where we can sneak in and i'll let you
do it
one very
primitive way
maybe it's primitive you tell me but
it's lo-fi way of identifying
possible trends through
you pointed out a stealth topic that
showed up in my most popular episodes in
the last 12 months yes so i'll let you
take that wherever you like totally so
what's the stealth topic so basically
i saw the list of the top 10 tim ferriss
podcasts you know last year
where i was number one and number two
despite how long they were so hopefully
the listeners got something out of it it
was an honor just to be nominated i'd
like to thank the academy yeah like they
very importantly by the way to my
knowledge the tim ferriss rankings are
not
juiced or editorialized and so on did
you know that you're probably aware of
this maybe your your listeners aren't
the new york times bestseller rankings
are an editorial product oh absolutely
i'm 100 aware of that because i had just
uh just to give an example one launch
week with one of my books which came out
through amazon publishing which put me
squarely in the crosshairs of almost
everyone in the traditional book slash
publishing world
sold i want to say a hundred and twenty
thousand copies through nielsen bookscan
for that one week and it was number four
on the new york times bestseller list in
my category
and the book that hit number two sold
somewhere between 10 and 12 000 copies
verified through nielsen books again
yeah so do you know what the exorcist
lawsuit i don't
okay i do not so basically back in the
80s the the guy who wrote you know the
book the exorcist which actually got
turned into a movie
sued the new york times because his book
hadn't been a different book legion it
hadn't been included in the bestseller
list and in their explicit written
defense in the courtroom nyt said the
the best seller list was actually
neither mathematically calculated nor
was it an objective measure of sales
rather it was editorial content and as
such was protected as free speech under
the us constitution right so
it's actually the most charitable
interpretation is like google's rankings
right google's google's rankings
you know what is the number one hit for
sinatra
okay now what's funny is you'll get a
different you know if you google it
you'll probably actually be surprised
for a long time it was the sinatra web
framework and now it's frank sinatra you
know the wikipedia article
and the thing is that's a great example
of what should it be most people who are
looking for sinatra are probably looking
for the web framework but most people on
the planet the most apology statement
ever but continue
do you think that's true
all right most people who are querying
sinatra as as opposed to frank sinatra
you're saying okay all right fair enough
because you know it's like a very proper
noun to query right yeah
so they're like if you could measure it
and google is kind of coming that when
it was good it was measuring this kind
of stuff their intent
basically you could argue as to what was
number one is it the thing that people
want to get
it's like searching for apple should it
be the fruit there or should it be you
know well actually if they look for
apples they want the fruit if they want
apple then they want the company right
that kind of thing right yeah anyway but
sinatra is a good example point being
that that's something at least google
people kind of know that the ranking is
not objective when you call it a
best-seller list the impression is that
it's a numerically ranked thing and it's
not editorialized but it is anyway point
b coming all the way back up tim
ferriss's unjuiced unedited list was
interesting because i looked at that
that's actually kind of some open source
analytics itself and when i when i
looked at that i was like you know it's
interesting there is a stealth topic
here which i'm also really interested in
that
tim's listeners are interested in and
i'm not sure it's being named as such
and that is transhumanism
and that's huberman lab that's life
extension that is brain machine
interface and it's limited generation
it's all your fitness stuff it is all
the recovery stuff and so on all of that
is sort of uh you know a whole
growing positive in my view positive
trend the problem is people have
pathologized that they think that
transhumanism is like the
i don't know the klaus schwab version
from the world economic forum where you
all become mishap and monsters and
you're edited and you know you're
quasimodo you know harvesting
adrenochrome from uh orphan children in
romania that's right so something like
that we need probably a different term
for it and i've got some terms that i've
been thinking about i think
you know there's like often you have the
the positive and the negative version of
any term like you can you know russell
conjugate it positively and negatively
like
you know
he was righteously angry or he was
incandescently
mad or whatever you know you can change
the tone of yeah the sweat transpire
glisten depending on
yeah exactly i you know i sweat he
perspires she glows right yeah so
whatever else you might call it i like
to use term optimalism
as opposed to optimism you are
optimizing yourself you are being
positive there's an objective function
transhumanism you you might say it's
just a change or that change is positive
or negative is unstated right but
optimalism is in a sense you're
improving you're getting better right it
is like optimal physical fitness it is
optimal health it is taking care of
oneself it is optimizing finances it is
optimizing everything very in tune with
i think what a lot of you know your
listeners are are for right so
that's that to me if you ask about
foreseeable futures transhumanism is an
all-weather thing or let's call it
optimalism people will want to get
better and i think science is now really
starting to catch up there and this is
actually one of the good things about
you know the state sort of receding and
coming back and not being able to like
the overturn window on this is
absolutely moving people are much more
skeptical of the fda and that actually
has good aspects because it means that
more treatments and so on can get
through um but all right so you asked
about foreseeable future so one of them
is optimalism transhumanism a second one
which i think is this is
this will be completely obvious to
pretty much everybody who's in let's say
big tech but maybe not as obvious to
people outside
is uh augmented reality glasses should i
talk about this
yeah absolutely okay so in the like late
90s
and
probably the early 2000s people talked
about the so-called convergence device
and you can go and look at the lexus
nexus archives and so on bill gates
would talk about the convergence device
and what what did he mean by that he
thought it was gonna be gonna be like a
television which would combine like a
computer
and a phone and all of these other
things why it's because you know in the
in the 80s and 90s everybody had a tv
and everybody talked about the tv and
the the household gathered around it and
they interacted with the remote so it
seemed like a reasonable thing
that people would be in habituated using
the tv could could do something else
right
and it turned out to actually the
convergence device was not the
television it was it was the phone that
acquired all of those characteristics
but they were correct that there was
going to be a convergence device and
there were also people who were
interested in quote mobile prior to the
iphone jack dorsey actually the reason
twitter i believe has 140 characters is
it was some like sms payload constraint
that you know he understood how
important mobile was going to be
years before the iphone even came out
right most people were not seeing that
most people even after the iphone came
out there's this great core thread
that's a time capsule that's something
like what's the point of mobile apps it
was like in 2010 actually and they're
like what's the point of mobile apps
it's just going to show me coupons as i
walk by a store
right
do you know what's right have i talked
about this i don't my friend yashan wong
he actually
i think he
replied to this let me see if i can find
this thread yeah okay without mentioning
coupons why and how is mobile the future
or will the next revolution really be
based around deals and incentives okay
i think it was from 2010 or something
like that right and the thing is
that post is a great time capsule
because from today's standpoint we're
like
what are mobile apps good for
everything everything is good mobile
right there's uber and there's airbnb
and there's google maps and on and on
and then when you actually go and think
about it the issue is that because
people have been so used to operating
computer in sessile fashion meaning
immobile
their imagination wasn't enough they're
like why would i just want to do that
on the go i don't i don't have a full
mouse i don't have a keyboard i have to
tap on a screen and so and so forth and
yashan's point was humans are mobile and
so therefore even if the interface is
smaller even if your ux is worse even if
it's more constrained and it can't do
everything it has that 1000x value
proposition that it's always available
to you at all times
and that alone means that every app will
become a mobile app this is totally
obvious
today it's probably pretty obvious by
2015. it was absolutely non-consensus by
like 2009-2010 when that thread came out
except for within the tech people who
are investing in mobile okay so
what is kind of similar to that
i i and of course not every future comes
to bear and so on and so forth but what
would i consider something which in like
five years or ten years are gonna be
like duh super obvious of course huh you
know and now today they think you're a
weirdo and that's never gonna happen
okay so that's that's a great
that you know when it goes from you're
stupid and insane and that'll never
happen too obviously that would always
be the way it was i love that because
there's a very short gap in the middle
of that exponential you know other
things that were like that were like
masks during covid or pseudonymity
actually in in the crypto community you
know but what a specific one so ar
glasses
so air glasses if you combine a few
things okay
so snapchat spectacles which to
spiegel's immense credit he has
persisted with after tons of criticism
and you know like hardware is really
hard to iterate on right so
he's persisted with that he's made that
a big thing
and i give him a lot of credit for that
because it's very difficult to do that
over multiple generations it's the kind
of thing that your cfo wants to cut it's
the kind of thing the street doesn't
like it can be low margin blah blah blah
anyway spectacles are out there i'm not
sure what how well they're doing but i i
they've definitely improved a lot i like
them
i have no snapchat stock by the way i'm
just saying it whatever thing it's a
good product so
spectacles facebook's oculus quest again
something which zuck deserves i think a
huge amount of credit for putting two
billion into that ten years ago they're
only now really starting to recruit
because there were several iterations
and there was a lot of technology that
needed to go into oculus quest to get to
where it is now oculus quest is so
spectacles oculus quest google glass
enterprise which i think is doing like
reasonably well
apple's ar so google glass enterprise
basically they're using it for
industrial applications not walking down
the street yet but for industrial
applications like like a surgeon or a
mechanic or something like that right
less likely to get punched in the face
when you're using it that way yeah right
well so come to that point apple's ar
kit right so ar kit is like you can hold
your phone up and you can see like a
glowing orb or something like that in
the other side or you you know for
example you've got a ruler app in the
phone and you can hold it up and it'll
just boom it'll show you blueprint style
what the measurements are of your walls
right and then you know apps like
pokemon go right
which are augmented reality apps and you
put all of that together and what do you
get you get something which looks and
feels just like a normal pair of glasses
that you'd get from from lenscrafter or
something like that but you tap it and
you get terminator vision over the world
and maybe you tap it again and it
darkens and you're in vr
okay and it's as lightweight as normal
glasses which we know are form factor
that people do use millions of people
use them every day
they look like normal glasses so they
don't like stick out to the world at
large
but what they do is they now make you
hands-free
right so remember the thing we were
saying why humans are always mobile well
why would people want ar glasses they
want the use of their hands
right they want to use their hands and
they want to be outside and they don't
want to be stuck inside all the time
and so this will make us truly mobile
again because you won't be you know
mobile phones will be seen as this
intermediate stage where you go and walk
around you're like you know like this
all the time right and
i'm not sure if it's huberman who said
this on your podcast or something but he
was like you know the way to wake up to
be alert is to like look up do you know
that trick
yeah i think he did
share that on
his in my first conversation on the
podcast i believe that was in that
episode
it's almost like you know you've got
like this primitive caveman and he's
coming out of the cave and he's like
who will og smash today you know looking
looking up like this you know and he's
like kind of surveying and he's alert or
whatever right that maybe that's the
adaptation but the opposite of that is
staring down at your phone and actually
sergey brin many years ago remarked that
it was emasculating to do that and who
knows what the
biomechanical feedback loop that's going
on is right but heads up is heads up
how much of the purpose of alexa as a
device in the home do you think is just
developing
training data
and
better tech so that it can be ported
over to
mobile use in some type of application
with say ar enabled classes
i mean it's a really good business in
its own right i mean i've sold tens if
not hundreds of millions of those
devices so but yeah the training data
helps helps a lot
all three companies you know apple
google and amazon have you know these
smart speaker things which are they're
kind of interesting right
if you snapchat today and then you think
back 30 years the kinds of things that
have converged you know the the clock
radio
has become this the closest analog to
that in the 1980s household for amazon
alexa thing is that
and the phone obviously has combined
lots and lots of different gadgets and
then we're gonna now see you know if you
look at like uh the solana crypto phone
when you walked out of your house in the
80s or 90s you'd have your wallet and
your keys and then maybe your credit
card and then later you have your phone
and literally a physical wallet and a
physical key and a credit card and so on
and eventually that's all going to
converge into a different kind of thing
because it's amazing that your cash and
your wallet
and your keys to your car and your
credit card can all be thought of as a
private key
on your phone
i suspect we're very close to that right
i mean you have tesla very close just
phone tethered and then you have say
apple
wallet
and then you have you know fill in the
blank we're very close to that i would
imagine we're close but it's one of
those things it's sort of like gathering
threads you know so you have to gather
all of the skins together so that now a
tesla car can be basically open by your
phone and then you have to sell so many
tesla cars that's like 10 of the market
you've educated the market and then you
do it for you know your walls with your
private keys and then you do it for your
passwords and so once you're gathering
all these different schemes and then you
you know make that tapestry or that coil
what is that word that you're using
skein
s-k-e-i-n
e-i-n all right
new word it's like a length of thread or
yarn a length of thread or a yarn
loosely coiled and knotted got it maybe
i'm mispronouncing it but i think it's
skein no you got it skein
all right yes you gathered the skeins
sorry to interject yes so you asked for
a foreseeable future so first is
transhumanism slash optimalism and
i just tweet which is uh super soldier
serum is real okay have you seen this
one
i have not
okay so you'll like this one all right
super chills of charm is real okay this
article is from plos it's like
15 years old or whatever oh this is like
myostatin inhibitors or something
yeah exactly and so on the left-hand
side wild-type mouse on the right-hand
side myostatin null and look at the
chest on that guy right like holy moly
so that's why i put like the captain
america before and after yeah if you are
able to work with knockout genes and so
on you end up with
animals like bully whippets so people
who have seen a whippet
will envision this very very very thin
dog that looks something like a
greyhound but if you look up a bully
whip it you'll see something very very
different indeed and there are also
cattle breeds
that are
have been bred selectively which is the
slow way to do it
for this type of myostatin inhibition so
they end up looking like arnold
schwarzenegger times 10 basically
exactly that's right and the thing is
that you know this movie limitless that
i really like
and the reason i like it is
it changes the normal hollywood formula
at the end see normally many hollywood
formula you know movies about science
fiction stuff nowadays have a sort of
icarus thing to them he flew he was too
bold and he flew too close to the sun
and his wings melted and he came back to
the earth and he should not have ever
flown in the first place you know and
and it's basically like you arrogant
technologist you added but
there's always some constraint and it
will be subtracted from you you'll never
learn or write this kind of intrinsic
conservatism
and uh what's awesome about it's a 10
year old movie so i'm spoiling it for
people but what's awesome about the end
of limitless is that he engineers away
that constraint
and because in real life guess what all
of our planes don't crash either
we managed to outdo icarus it wasn't
like some arrogance of thinking we could
fly we could fly right we could figure
it out yes there were some crashes
we figured out we got it down to a not
just a science but to an engineering and
so similarly a lot of people when you
show stuff like this myostatin thing or
whatever they'll be like
oh
but it'll give you cancer or you know
steroids will screw you up man or
whatever i'm like
that it may be the case if you are not
throwing all the science and engineering
in the world at it but like okay so
here's a kind of controversial statement
you know lance armstrong the tour de
france
winner who cheated and right yep
okay well here's the thing
i may be getting some of the facts wrong
with this but my understanding is he had
serious testicular cancer his doctors
gave him some kind of treatment and then
he did like
he came back to win multiple tour de
frances right like he was out racing
other guys many of whom were also juiced
okay but the point is yes
within the game sure he broke the rules
should be punished i don't dispute any
of that from an abstract perspective i
want to know what his chemists were
doing because that is some like nobel
prize worthy stuff to bring back
somebody from testicular cancer to that
level of physical fitness
is
insane whatever it was that they were
doing now is it possible people again
they'll come up with the icarus line
what are you talking about he probably
dropped five years off his life okay
maybe he did i actually don't know
but if he did i think a lot of people
might still take that trade off in the
trade-off space to come from testicular
cancer to like ridiculously ultra fit
and so on but five years less of life i
don't actually think that's a necessary
thing again go ahead let me hop in here
because this is this is one domain where
i have i have some familiarity so for
people who want to
get an idea of how doping functions at
the highest levels or the higher levels
at the highest levels you'd need to get
the actually there's a film called
icarus of all things
oh really a documentary which goes into
the soviet state's
use of doping and from a biochemical and
also even just mechanical logistics
perspective it's staggeringly complex
and fascinating i think there's a book
also it's quite old
but called game of shadows barry bonds
balco and the steroid scandal that
rocked professional sports which is also
a
a quite a good read when it comes to
assuming you don't want to get into too
much of the biochemistry but let me say
just two things
uh so one is related to lance it's their
arguments have been made
that
until he lost muscle mass through cancer
treatment
primarily in his upper body
that he was an excellent cyclist but not
of the caliber that we saw afterwards
and that part of the success not all of
it but a component to the increased
level of success again it's a new
version of like balkan cut it was the
recomposition of
of his body and distribution of muscle
mass i do think the lance example is
super interesting and
i would just also pick up
on one lost
lost skein i'll use skein
from earlier if people want to see
examples of literally they're referred
to as double muscled cattle
these are mutations due to mutations in
the coding sequence of bovine myostatin
belgian blue
is the one that you can most easily find
and this the photographs of this are
quite mind-boggling
oh yeah it's great yep the traps on that
thing are just crazy everything it
doesn't even look like they should be
able to walk and in some cases due to
selective breeding and other types of
interventions that is the case with
chickens now who are bred for
consumption that you know they can't
support their own weight on their legs
past whatever it is and making it up
something like week six but i don't want
to take us too far afield we're going to
come back to the network state wait wait
i want to talk about this thing you just
said let's come to the networks here
okay yeah so one thing that's kind of
important about this is and this will
relate to the networks you think is um
you know the title epic game of shadows
and some of the words cheat and
fraud and you know so and so forth the
fundamental issue and even with the
soviets and so on right all of this
stuff is being done
in the shadows it's on the border of the
system it's by the bad guys
what it reminds me of is actually in the
soviet union itself there were two kinds
of groups that talked about capitalism
the the first
were the
dissidents
the
the guys who eventually became reformers
and so on and so forth that was a tiny
tiny tiny minority of people they're the
people who could get outside of
their childhood and all the propaganda
on how evil those capitalists were
weren't they imperialists weren't they
pointing guns at us hadn't they killed
our brave soviet soldiers had a lenin's
revolution and everybody sacrificed so
that you the worker could have this
bountiful life and you're so ungrateful
and evil so that there's that small
group of academic types who could get
outside their head but there was a much
larger second group of capitalists you
know what those guys were tell me
the black marketeers
and they lived down to every stereotype
of the regime they would cut you for
some vodka
they were totally unregulated shadow
capitalists so are those guys team
biology i'm just trying to no
no
tying this together my point is that
when our moral premise
in the soviet union the moral premise
was capitalism is bad and when if
capitalism is a crime only criminals
will be capitalists
right yeah and it took enormous amount
of effort over 70 years to flip that
moral premise and be like look
capitalism is at least acceptable if not
good and then what happens is all of
this stuff you unlock the basic
dispassionate
gears of civil society you have
accounting and you have supply chains
and you have financing you have all this
stuff that we think of as like boring
corporate stuff where it comes out of
the shadows into you have courts that
deal with edge cases because in the
abstract basically once you've denounced
capitalism and pushed it into a corner
the soviets could say and what happens
if someone cheats you huh well that's
what happens under capitalism and the
answer is yes it does true that scams or
whatever do happen but we have courts
and we have mechanisms and you know in
in the abstract the whole thing can be
denounced as obviously unworkable and so
complicated you have all these edge
cases you have the chancery court which
determines in the liquidation who gets
you know what kind of
outcome
you have you have seen your debt you
have all this type of stuff right
meaning sorry i know i'm mixing a few
things point is you have like delaware
law and corporate law you have
liquidation preferences you have
went from belgium blue to delaware
corporate law in 27 seconds i i like it
the range yeah the point is basically
that there are a lot of details when you
actually come and implement capitalism
and from the app outside if you haven't
done that it makes it sound like
too complicated a rube goldberg machine
that'll never work why don't we just you
know seize everything comrade and and
redistributed from the state
and the thing that's already there is
the thing that's functioning and the
thing that isn't there is a thing that
seems can be attacked in a thousand ways
is the system that doesn't exist totally
point is once that moral premise got
flipped once it was allowed for the bulk
of 99 of people to engage in this yeah
there's a whole machinery that comes in
and so once we can flip that moral
premise and we can say
look
life extension is good and more muscle
is good and the whole icarus narrative
is wrong the wright brothers are right
icarus is a myth right right brothers
that's a reality right we actually were
able to fly icarus is just a mythical
thing the reality is a boeing 747 right
or or whatever airbus you know name name
some recent flying aviation company that
hasn't had some issues but whatever
right the overall you know planes work
so in the same way once we flip that
moral premise and say optimalism good
enhancement good
then we start shifting it out of game of
shadows and soviets and you know the
doping scandals and cheating all those
negative adjectives and we start going
to the positive stuff of you know what
huberman is doing and what david
sinclair is doing and so on and so forth
i the reason i just want to identify
this i actually think that moral
language that moral premise
is everything and it's often not
articulated no i i agree with you and
just like making the market
setting the price depth charts
we talked a bit about the overton window
and sort of uh
shifting that depth chart as a way of
becoming political if you're an active
player so to speak and i think that also
applies here i just want to say a couple
of things about
the doping and performance enhancement
just for people who may be interested in
going a little bit deeper
another documentary and you could learn
a lot just by watching
first i would suggest
bigger faster
i always say bigger faster stronger it's
bigger faster stronger but i think for
trademark purposes they probably flipped
it bigger stronger faster is a
documentary that was
that was made in 2008 and it is a
fascinating exploration of performance
enhancement and it also shows
the advantages that
richer countries have in performance
and in a sense
doping and competition at the highest
levels is very similar to
let's call it tax optimization on the
positive side tax evasion
if you want to
look at it through that lens they will
look at something like in this
documentary use of erythropoietin so epo
used to increase the oxygen carrying
capacity of your blood right which is
why athletes also will use blood doping
so they might have use of epo
banned by
wada right so you cannot do this in the
realm of sports that's against the rules
then you have blood doping which at
different points and in different
capacities has been either allowed or
not allowed it's the same thing right if
you train at altitude and then you
develop blood that has more oxygen
carrying capabilities and then you
infuse yourself with that that's kind of
quadrant two then you have quadrant
three which is like sleeping in an
altitude simulation tent so what are the
axes sorry i didn't i missed the axes
what are they uh i forget about the axes
for now it's just comparing four
different options and then there are a
few others and it's just to point out
that
the
and again i don't want to dwell on this
too long but the
the
you can look at four approaches to
achieving the same ends with different
legal
status or different status with respect
to the rules
which
doesn't automatically mean all of them
should be allowed in my opinion but
secondarily like there are countries
that do not have
olympic sized swimming pools to train in
and nonetheless have athletes who are
sent to the olympics to compete in
swimming right
so i i do think that there are
in some respects
incentives that are aligned with
athletes to preserve
the current state of doping because with
more money with more state support you
can actually game the system more
effectively than
not necessarily lesser players but less
resourced
players
so i would just say that i don't think
all athletes would want to
agree to nor teams nor states to
say the all drug olympics if people
haven't seen the all drug olympics skit
from saturday night live they should
look it up it's actually pretty
entertaining let me poke on this a
little bit because let me add one more
thing and then you can poke on this too
i would also say definitely i'm not a
doctor i don't plan on the internet but
people should
muscle mass is good to a point
preserving muscle mass avoiding
age-related muscle
atrophy like sarcopenia super important
bone density etc but there are arguments
to be made that
stepping on the gas with anabolism
could be
contraindicated
for
longevity past a certain point
so i would just say there's a there's a
balancing act between sort of autophagy
and and a number of things we know work
for longevity as it stands right now at
least in mice and and possibly in
canines
and
that
balance is something i think people
should should look at there will be a
future guest on this podcast dr matt
cable line that conversation is going to
get into a lot of that
but please uh feel free to push back or
tease apart this one thing i actually i
love this it's great i'm learning stuff
also but i think
the the framing of it in terms of
athletes and the olympic games or drug
olympic games and so on the thing is you
know as you're aware in this century or
in this sort of phase of humanity we're
moving away from spectator sports and
like
i i don't really care that much about
the olympics or the nfl or something
like that but i do care about physical
fitness and running and you know lifting
and so on and so forth
so
fine for somebody who wants to go and do
it professionally but i do care about
the average person's health and for the
average person or you know any person
that's not a game the absolute metric is
what is their personal muscle mass what
is that you know when 100 people run
around a track maybe one of them wins
but all of them the other 99 also get a
cardiovascular benefit from that right
and that's kind of what i'm focused on
is
not the zero-sum aspect of who wins this
zero-sum competition where it's like
this artificial and constrained
environment but rather the
non-zero sum of how do we improve
people's health across the population
generally even if it is true that these
guys who are like extreme elite
competitors have something to teach us
broadly
like
nothing on the field really matters to
anybody outside the field beyond the
entertainment unless there's some cool
discoveries that come out of there and
we're we're curing testicular cancer or
or we're having treatments for them that
make them
run around like lance armstrong after
after his thing that's that's kind of
where i'm coming from yeah i think we're
more on the same page
than than
you might imagine oh yeah yeah the point
i'm making is that the dose makes the
poison right paracelsus with so many
things and this includes a volume of
exercise it includes drug intake
and
much like we were talking about
technology and looking around corners
and seeing what will be obvious or at
least
widespread say five years from now you
can do that with performance enhancement
sports very easily too you look at
racehorses and then you look at say
patients with wasting diseases who are
using various interventions because it
is their or they view it as their means
of last resort and then you have
bodybuilders and then professional
athletes and then you have rich people
right so if you just kind of track that
progression
you can spot a lot of things super early
that's a great funnel yeah you can spot
say modafini yes and provisional things
like that 10 years before it's widely
widely known as a possible performance
enhancer for cognition which i would not
recommend people do
by the way it's still pretty poorly
understood honestly just monitoring that
funnel and publishing that funnel on a
quarterly basis would be one of the most
important newsletters yeah that would be
an awesome funnel to kind of track i put
it into the four hour body when i wrote
it in 2008 2009 it's still reliable you
can track that stuff it does require
some
manual labor just because sure
competitive horse trainers aren't just
going to sit down with you over a cup of
tea the first time you meet and tell you
all about their doping regimen right
for
a lot of understandable reasons
i agree with you on you know the exact
dose of something more is not always i
agree with all that the only thing that
i'm saying is just
and it seems like a small thing but it's
like
i i just don't like to even use words
like
doping shadows cheating etcetera because
that is conceding
territory
to folks that want to pathologize
improvement
and that's the only thing i'm coming at
is it like to sort of pull the chip
that's that limiter chip that's in our
heads you know and and remove that chip
and basically like actually no limits
so i think i think it is important to
develop an awareness of
the words you use because at least if
you understand those words they sort of
form the concepts and the boundaries of
your thinking
at least the boundaries of what you deem
acceptable and unacceptable right so you
should be very aware of the language you
use
again i don't want to dwell too long on
this i will just say that if the
opposite of pathologizing
use of
just to choose one class like anabolic
androgenic steroids if the opposite of
pathologizing it is
is freedom in the form of
anyone taking however much they want
whenever they want i don't think
that
swing to the opposite end of the
pendulum is going to be a net positive
for people so so the awareness is
important but as is the due diligence
right
like i have used a whole slew of these
compounds post-surgically to ensure full
recovery of my left shoulder which i had
completely reconstructed and i've talked
about this publicly because i'm not
ashamed of it i think it was absolutely
strategically medically
the right thing to do i'm not
recommending people do that there are
both medical
and legal consequences that can follow
from all these things
so
speak to your gp speak to your physician
if you want to discuss this kind of
thing
but
i i just want to make it clear that i'm
not just an observer in this sphere
i do think there are times and places
where it makes a lot of sense to use
these extremely powerful molecules but
they can be
misused with long-term consequences
totally so two things there one is the
reason that the soviet example is
actually quite good is
they would also kind of jump to oh so
you're for capitalism well then
everyone can auction everything at all
times and everything is always you know
prices and evil hedge funders will take
your and the thing is that all i'm
saying is let's not pathologize this
let's not put this in a box let us
actually
think i mean
you don't have to go to the other
extreme of
voided up whatever whatever you know the
thing that jumps to people's minds
there's an entire infrastructure an
entire continuum that can be built out
when we're not just balled up in the
corner of
game of shadows and cheats and doping
and and pathologization that's all i'm
saying it is a great title though it is
a great title just the fact that you
remembered it and have said it so many
times it's a good title you got to be i
mean i know it's not your style of title
oh it's a great title
it's like death tax it sticks it sticks
in your head right it's deliberate so
that's exactly right i mean there's
actually this amazing app
you know that people it came out
recently dolly too okay yeah what i'd
love about have you ever heard about
this you seen this i have i have access
to dolly too you've access here great
good yeah so and there's also like open
source not open sources there's more
public versions that people can mess
around so the thing is
that shows the power of words
more
to somebody who's of a quantitative bent
more than anything i could say
because you can write
three words into dolly two and get an
image
out from it and it's uh it's effectively
like an extremely compact programming
language i'd say like biology improving
musculature i don't know something like
that that yeah yeah yeah crazy good
point is that if you were to actually
write that out in computer code to build
some of those images it would be
thousands tens hundreds of thousands of
lines of code for some of them but you
can literally do it in like three words
and you know when people say oh you know
i'm not a i'm not a number i'm a name
there's actually a wisdom to that
because
words are like these super high
dimensional vectors
and
you can combine them to these really
complicated manipulations in just a few
phrases
and what's kind of interesting is that
three different technologies are all
converging on the power of really really
short phrases and those are ai as we
just talked about you know where you
just give a few words and the computer
is able to figure out all of this stuff
crypto where you have 12 words or 13 or
14 words and it's a mnemonic which
stores all of your cryptocurrency
right i mean literally you could store
like 100 million dollars in like those
those words you know you could store all
these possessions
and then obviously social media where a
few words can be a hashtag or a phrase
that starts an entire movement and that
is on every building and everybody
quotes and so on and so forth so those
three points by the way why those three
technologies i know it's almost seems
trite to say ai crypto and social but
those three technologies are in a sense
like cognitive or social technologies in
a way that rocket ships and
internal combustion engines are not
because those don't interact with humans
these do you know these touch humans in
different ways
anyway so so basically i have grown i
used to kind of
think that all the word games that they
played in academia in the humanities
weren't that important and it was just
bore me as to why they were doing this
and now i realize it's like insanely
important because
a slight tonal shift in a word that
russell conjugation thing we were
talking about you would get a totally
different looking dolly to image
based on the tone sure that's a good
point yep and that makes it
concrete right yeah so that's why
basically
building our own vocabulary and thinking
about it consciously from the beginning
sometimes coming up with words for
example you know this guy
peter turchin okay who i like
some of his work uh i do not so he came
up with a term which he calls clio
dynamics right and like clio dynamics
is
cleo is like the muse of history and
essentially the concept is he named this
term
it's like the science of history it's
like a
quantitative form of history and so he
just took that term cleo and he put it
in front and it's kind of a nice
sound to it and it's kind of cool and he
just made that word and he's using that
word and i think it's a great word right
and what this is similar to by the way
is if you're an engineer
and you're writing code what you'll find
is and you probably do this actually
when you're writing your book you'll
find that you write
a hundred or a thousand or five thousand
lines of code and there's certain
concepts certain nouns and verbs that
you keep using and then you you know
sometime on line 3700 you're like oh
that noun
is actually the core data structure of
my entire program and that verb is the
core function of the whole thing it's a
little bit like you're writing a book
and on chapter three you're like wow
that should be like the title of the
chapter yeah or the book or the book
that's how a lot of people work or a
screenplay right they come up with the
title on page 78
where it somehow emerges as a theme with
a label yes
let's talk about the network state
let's start
with the simple question
which is what is
what on earth is a network state
we were just talking about words and
this is you know something which is
chosen for this purpose to kind of have
several different definitions
so i've got a definition of it and then
i've got like several different ways to
talk about it so here's a definition and
then it won't seem
informative then i'll go through it or
at least it'll seem like a mouthful so a
network state is a social network with a
moral innovation a sense of national
consciousness a recognized founder a
capacity for collective action an
in-person level of civility an
integrated cryptocurrency an archipelago
of crowdfunded physical territories
a virtual capital and an on-chain census
that proves a large enough population
income and real estate footprint to
attain a measure of diplomatic
recognition okay now you might be like
jesus that's like that's not a sentence
that's a paragraph and the thing is that
there's tons of things which are very
simple to
describe or interact with but very
complicated to implement
and you know for example google has this
really simple interface of you type
something into it but to implement
google is actually quite
difficult
and in particular if you asked me to
define not what a networks it is but
what a nation state is
people will kind of have a tough time
doing that you know they might say oh
it's kind of like regions on the map or
something like that it's a country right
but
when you you want to give like a precise
definition that's not like a circular
definition
the the term nation state for example
first nation and state means something
different
nation
comes from the root word uh same root as
like natality it's like from common
birth you know and so a nation that's
like a group of people with a common
culture like the japanese people and
they have
a japanese language and japanese culture
and they're ethnically japanese and so
on and so forth and the state is the
system of laws and government that that
nation sets up to manage its own affairs
and they're as different as let's say
labor and management in a factory
okay and the same nation could have very
different states on top of it
there's some you know place like france
is aware of this because they have had
many different kinds of governments and
so on on top
but
in our day-to-day language the nation
and the state are conflated for example
you'll hear the term national security
or
multinational or
national as a synonym for federal
as national meaning like the entire but
they're actually conflating things
because really a multinational
it's not like
it's operating with the
japanese nation and the catalonian
nation and the kurdish nation and so on
it's multi-jurisdictional it's operating
in this jurisdiction and that
jurisdiction it sounds like
so so the word underneath has kind of
gotten abused
similarly like national security it's
really like state security it's not
really the security of the people
they're sort of abusing a term right so
there's been this drift in this kind of
confusion
and the reason for that is that states
want to identify themselves with the
nation
in the same way that
you know management wants to identify
itself as being the same as labor and to
not have a division between the two now
sometimes that's good and sometimes
that's bad
it's good if management is actually
aligned with labor
and economically aligned and so on it's
bad if management is disaligned and in
the stereotypical case of like the evil
co exact with the golden parachute
that's a bad case right
and so in the same way when people try
to make this extremely tight
identification between the state and the
nation
it's not actually the case the the
people can have a totally different
government if they so choose to shrug it
off and that tiny layer of folks that
are in the government
just gets deprecated and a new
government is set up if people pull
their pointers away and they set up a
new thing that's what happened for
example in the former soviet union when
when the soviet governments fell okay so
my my point is that
these things that we interact with on a
daily basis we don't usually have to go
to first principles and define them from
scratch right you know if we just talk
about the definition of a nation state
the reason i want to talk about that for
a second is
it will be more clear why the nation
state is a complicated thing and why a
network state has a multi-clausal
definition because each one of those
clauses takes care
of
a different failure mode because there's
all these different people who tried to
start new countries
and
just like a venture capitalist deal will
have this term and that term it'll have
they'll have drag along it'll have
liquidation it'll have pro-radar rights
and so on every single term in this in
this contract
anticipate some conflict or failure that
had happened in the past and that's why
it's a more complicated contract and the
same with this definition of a network
state goes through a ton of different
kinds of failures from
just putting a flag on an oil platform
and trying to call that a country to
going and trying to start a war and so
on there's many different ways that
people have failed to start new
countries
and this definition i think is
constructed to
route around all of them okay so that's
why it's a complicated definition all
right but first let me just kind of talk
about
the definition of a nation-state right
and
so first like the the nation itself
we just talked about how that is
you know this this body of people that's
united by common descent history culture
or language and the state is the
government but even that question of
okay fine what's what is a nation
you can actually drill into it and all
of these thinkers all these famous
thinkers you know rousseau and hegel and
marx and mill all these guys that you
read about in in school you may vaguely
remember it
all of them are now actually something
that an entrepreneur or someone who's
very applied would have to think about
why is that because
if in the 2010s we started to ask a
question that we had never really asked
in the 2000s and that question was what
is a currency
okay
in the 2020s we're going to start asking
the question what is a nation
and it actually becomes something where
you know the thing we took for granted
just a quick question nation or a state
nation first what is a nation okay what
is a nation because
the nation comes before the state
you could have a nation without a state
for example the kurds are a group of
people that have a common ethnicity and
culture and so on but they don't
actually have a state the catalonians
they're in the territory of the spanish
with the spanish state governments but
there are people without a state
and actually when you think about this
right like
the united nations is actually a
misnomer it's more like the selected
nations that happen to have their states
okay there's actually a guy you know the
guy who's currently running kazakhstan
and he's like
we can't endorse the principle of
self-determination for every nation
because we'd go from 192 in the u.n to
like 600 nations 600 because all of
these new states would pop up rather
because there's all of these hundreds of
nations around the world that do not
have their own state
the thing is when you start seeing it
this way it's a lens on the map
that
most people just don't think about it's
a you're turning a constant into a
variable and that is when we talked
about earlier about volatility
increasing
the biggest way that you can increase
volatility is you turn something that
you were a total consensus on and 100 of
people agreed on into something that
only 80 or 70 or 60 or 50 of people
agree on and when you do that when you
take that constant you turn into a
variable
all kinds of assumptions change if
you're a programmer for example
you know
the difference between operating and
assuming that it's just the united
states
or just in english versus coding your
program to work in every country in
every language
is an enormous change
it can be done but it's like
it's a significant difference concretely
why do i say constants are becoming
variables well there are pc examples i
can point out and there's npc examples
let's do both
all right let's do both okay well
constant two genders variable and
genders okay that's a great example of a
constant that became a variable where
there was something that was simply an
assumption in the 2000s that very much
turned into a variable and
literally all kinds of back-ends and
you know databases had to get rewritten
turning something that was assumed as a
constant interval
another example is
the us dollar
like before the before bitcoin no one
really thought that
that was a variable
and now it is it's a huge variable it's
something that a significant fraction
thinks of every day
as something that they can swap in or
swap out to at some percentage and it's
no longer you know it's no longer the
thing that you must reform it is the
thing that you can exit from
and
once you kind of start seeing this that
constants are becoming variables
you start seeing it across life and very
roughly speaking
you have
the
you know i'll just use this phrasing all
right but you have the woke and the tech
who are both sort of in different ways
disaligned with each other but also
aligned with each other in terms of
turning all social political constants
into variables and all
economic
things into variables let me give the
tech side because it's easier to talk
about
for example
is a meeting
is it in person
or is it virtual now we have to actually
choose right oh uh are you when you're
reading that book are you reading that
book physically are you reading the
digital copy simply the digital version
of everything starts introducing
combinatorial complexity right oh you're
talking to somebody was it on the phone
or is it one of these like 10 different
apps right
are you watching the news well it's no
longer cbs abc nbc but it's like
whatever number of different things okay
now there's a good to that there's
there's alternatives there's choice
there's all this type stuff obviously
people have said there's a bad oh my god
you know people are living in their own
filter bubbles really they're mad that
there's more than one filter bubble but
basically this is great decentralization
great fragmentation so all these
constants are becoming variables on the
economic side and tech is pushing that
and then on the political side woke is
pushing that and lots of things that
people just sort of took for granted
for example
you know the the police right do you
have a society with police people kind
of just thought of that as a constant
and then you have a significant
double-digit percentage of the
population less today but that was
actually saying defund the police right
abolish the police and you have an nyt
op-ed that says yes we really mean
defund the police
that's a big variable right that's a
huge enormous change that is a what i
call in the book that i call that a
moral flipping or moral inversion where
something that was good becomes bad or
bad becomes good
and
when you have something like that you
start to actually create different
nations
because you have the fundamental
premises of what are good and bad in a
population
change
and the us is not really a nation state
arguably it never was but it's not
really a nation state at a minimum it's
a bi-national
republic which has the red and blue
nations underneath it and you can see
this there's graphs
like for example uh there's a cgr
article from 2017 that i link
where you can actually see on social
media that the red and the blue are
literally like different clusters
and and it pops out to you you know they
just literally only linked to each other
and one way of looking at this that's
really unambiguous is if you look at
marriage patterns
people typically will say that they will
marry
across their race but you know what
democrats will only marry democrats to a
higher percentage and republicans are
tending to only want to marry other
republicans and that is being growing
right and the thing is that you iterate
that out one generation and what happens
that becomes ethnicity
right ideology becomes biology if your
political party is so important to you
that you are not going to marry outside
it
then in like one generation it becomes
at a minimum like protestant catholic or
sunni shiite or something like that huda
tootsie whatever right
you know it becomes something that's
actually tribal as opposed to
ideological the ideology changes the
biology
so these are things where there are
extremely deep questions where you just
didn't even have to think of them as
variables because you're born into a
world where they've been fixed as
constants
let me pause there get your thoughts
well i was just going to ask how does
the
network state solve for this or
codify it up front or allow for those
types of moral flippings
great questions the short answer is that
it says that the nation
is the network that forms online
that is defined by the moral premises
they share
and you literally have like a survey
okay which is
the good bad survey and sometimes
explicit is better than implicit for
example
the founder of this community
actually has something which is like i
believe
capitalism is good bad law enforcement
is good bad entrepreneurship is good bad
human improvement is good bad
you know two genders are good bad and so
on and so forth you have a set of
preferences right and some of them are
going to be not the extremely hot button
issues but they're going to be things
like
carbs good bad and so on and so forth
okay and i'll come to that actually i
know it sounds funny but
one of the things
about this is
once you define a community
on the basis of what they think is good
and bad
it's so strong
it's ridiculously strong because they
agree on the basic premises
and then they can crowdfund that you
don't have politics in the same way
because they don't have internal
disagreement they have alignment they
agree on what the good world should be
and then they can crowdfund things they
can appoint leaders they are essentially
organically aligned for a cause
and
that filtering of the internet into
these network nations is actually the
first step what it's not and the reason
this the whole you know the definition
is all these clauses to give you some
examples of failure modes right
if you go to youtube and you look at
like how to start a new country or
whatever you know what all the things
start with like they're kind of joke
videos but they're kind of funny you
know what they all start with what do
they start with get some land
and they're like but all the land is
spoken for blah blah blah blah right so
it's just immediate like the first step
they take is the wrong step
why
because land is the most contentious
zero-sum
insanely
fought over thing i mean russia and
japan are fighting over the corals and
like there's little islands in the
mediterranean that the turkish and greek
states are fighting over people fight
over land so much over the stupid you
know canada and denmark were fighting
over this stupid
uninhabited piece of land did you know
what i'm talking about
no it doesn't surprise me but it wasn't
silent humans like to fight hans island
okay here's the thing why would they
fight over something like hans island if
you go and look at it okay it's this
uninhabited
frozen island in the middle of nowhere
the non-obvious thing very non-obvious i
think
is that they can see it on a map
okay there was a in the in the 1800s
there was this
fight in the uh conflict it was called
5440 or fight are you familiar with this
say that one more time
probably not
54 54-40 or fight
no
i was i was stuck looking up the
falkland islands because i was thinking
about the falkland islands in this
context as well the eastless malvinas
but i don't i don't know 5440 or fight
okay so 544 fight was basically this
mid-1800s
conflict
over the boundary in the pacific
northwest
and you know the
the thing is is basically like we are
going to get the americans wanted the
border with uh you know what we would
now call canada to be at 5440 or they
would fight a war right now in actuality
it wasn't i think it turned out to be
like the 49th parallel rather than 5440
but the thing is think about that the
latitude and longitude
okay this
this thing this map construct that
everybody could share became something
that lots of eyes were on and then they
were fighting over it
right
okay now you might say that's like the
most obvious thing in the world biology
why which of course they'll fight over a
map they can see a map etc but
let me complicate that picture
first is
the map was actually not always visible
in you know pre-1492 much the world was
unmapped
the entire new world was not mapped and
maps actually just got better and better
and there you know for a long time there
was like there be dragons you know there
were parts of the world that were
unmapped there was what's called terra
incognita right
and there was this time of mystery you
know it's it was the frontier but as a
frontier to the nth power because you
didn't even know the land existed
right
and it kind of seems like we'll never
actually have that again until we get to
space
but i argue it's actually existing again
already in a non-obvious way and that is
on the internet
point is when people can see something
they will fight over it you know the the
concept of mimesis right if they can see
it they'll fight over it so you can see
hans island they fight over it they see
a border they fight over it and you can
see for example the franco-german border
between france and germany you know the
border you can't see
is the border between twitter and
facebook and what do i mean by that what
is the border between twitter and
facebook well twitter has like 330
million users facebook has 3.6 billion
and for each person you could define the
border as
for their time
spent on so let's say this that's you
know 3.6 million facebook users 330
million twitter users
the total is 3.93 billion max it might
be like 3.7 there might be an overlap
there okay
for each person you can define a zero to
a hundred percent in terms of the time
that they would spend on either 100
twitter or 100 facebook right
the border region would be those people
who are 50 50.
and that might be a group of
70 million people in the world who spend
exactly 50 of their time and there's
people who are farther from the border
who are 30 70 and people who are really
far from the border near the capital who
are 100 and vice versa okay what i'm
describing there is literally something
that you could compute it's not an
abstract thing if you had access to all
of twitter's data set and all of
facebook's data set you could compute
this here's the thing nobody has access
to both
so nobody can compute it
or you can estimate it and so on but
unless you know like twitter and
facebook got acquired they wouldn't be
able to literally find out who was on
the border region they could do sampling
and stuff but there's a cloud that is
descended right these gigantic networks
cannot really see their borders that
well
they can see themselves but they can't
see what people are doing outside they
have less
control in a sense right
and less visibility and so instead what
they'll fight over are the visible
things
like you know the use of the network and
so on and so forth but they're going to
fight over border regions less the only
way they can fight over a border region
is to make their products so attractive
they can pull people from that border
region now by the way lest it me said
that these are like trivial things to
talk about twitter's 330 million people
facebook's 3.6 billion both of those are
bigger than france and germany combined
you know
these are these are enormous enormous
networks it's like a huge chunk of
humanity and the fact that we cannot see
the border region means that the entire
geography of like how humans operate is
actually changing you have to kind of
remap how you think about geography
because in physical space
for example two people you know they're
they're near each other there's a
physical distance metric and so on in
digital space it's like a bunch of
islands that can snap to like i can be
near you as i am right now and then snap
away and be really far right and that
applies not just for individuals but for
entire continents so for example in the
physical world
russia is basically always going to be
adjacent to
japan and ukraine and iran and so in
like russia the country doesn't move
around that much
i mean its borders can expand and
contract with the soviet union it's
bigger when it's the russian federation
it's smaller but it's not like it's
suddenly adjacent to argentina right
it's not suddenly adjacent to mexico it
could you know like it did it was
involved in the cuban missile crisis at
the at the height of its power but it's
not like projecting power all over the
world
by contrast
somebody like
you know vitalik of ethereum his network
of people right
or you know the uh the solana network
suddenly
this network can be adjacent to another
network solana can start taking users
from ethereum it's like this huge island
of like 30 million people just surfaced
out of the ocean next to japan and
started like pulling people from them
godzilla yes godzilla anyway
yeah exactly right so it's like atlantis
is real digital atlantis this huge
island what the heck right and and it
can then disappear and vanish and you
can also vanish you know
your thing can kind of be like hey you
know we want to
we want to cut off those network
relations if we want to move our island
somewhere else right so the thing is
that i'm downloading one of about i
don't know how many 10 15 different
things that turn constants into
variables one of them is
the nation
that we we take for granted the single
group of people is breaking up into
multiple nations that are defined by
networks another is the currency is
breaking up okay a third is the
geography is changing
a fourth is the moral principles that
underpin society are changing
and so when like all those things are in
flux you kind of need something to catch
it on the other side because otherwise
what people will do is they will sort of
try to assert that old thing that just
doesn't exist anymore and that'll be
like
something that does not acknowledge the
reality of the situation it's like
opening the you know closing the barn
door and then expecting get all the
horses back inside
when
there were forces that were more
powerful than that thing that that
spread them all out that those entropic
forces you have to kind of go to where
those horses are and loop them up and
maybe have new branches or whatever
there to to extend the metaphor
okay so what i'd love to do
is
and this is just how i like to think
about teaching in general like if you're
teaching someone a golf swing like you
sho you show them once you do it side by
side then you have them take a couple of
free swings and then
provide feedback after that sure what
i'd like to do is just paint a picture
or get your help to paint a picture of
where we might be going and then we can
back into digging into some of the nuts
and bolts and concepts
of the network states so
i'd like to
to break that into two pieces so let me
let me just set a framework if i may
so it could be five years it could be
ten years or whatever time frame but
let's just kind of pick a time frame
maybe it's five years but you can pick
the first is just take a few minutes to
paint a picture for where you see
america
in a handful of years right whatever and
again you can pick the the distance just
so we have an idea and you have had some
predictive accuracy with a number of
things over the last handful of podcast
conversations so
just to set the stage for like okay if
if your
default is kind of do nothing don't move
this is what you might see coming based
on a b and c and then just a few minutes
on that and then after that painting a
picture
of if you were taking the pro side of a
bet so let's just say you're talking to
some politician and they're like ah
biology you're full of [ __ ] blah blah
blah u.s is going to be this this and
this and not much is going to change and
i'm going to bet a million dollars that
this network state thing is not going to
be a thing and you said okay i'm going
to take a million dollars on the other
side of the bet
and here's the picture i'm going to
paint as a possibility and because when
i hear network state you know a lot of
things come to mind i'm listening very
carefully i'm thinking on one hand of
like e-citizenship in estonia and how
that might be tweaked because most of
the people who are getting this
e-citizenship have no plans to actually
reside in estonia right and then i'm
thinking on the other hand like
christiania
this
basically
started as a sort of squatters
territory within copenhagen in denmark
that has its own social structure of
sorts its own economy of sorts
right i'm i have a lot of these free
floating ideas but if you could just
talk about like okay
a handful of years out what your vision
of the u.s looks like and what might
change and then if you had to paint a
picture of like
if i had to bet on a nation-state coming
into existence and getting some traction
this is what i could see happening and
then we can back into the rest of it so
let me start with the first part first
this is just a scenario analysis
i
don't want to say it's a base case let's
say i think it's probable i can't say
it's 100 and there's always there's
there's things that happen
that
are reactions to trends you predict but
it's hard to predict exactly what that
reaction is but here it goes
i call it american anarchy chinese
control the international intermediate
and the recentralized center okay this
is my sort of base level world view for
what happens the next five ten years so
what is american anarchy so i actually
wrote about this for barry weiss's
newsletter last year how we changed our
minds in 2021 but the short version is
some groups think everything will
basically be as it is the so-called what
tyler cohen calls base raiders they just
think everything is going to be the same
everybody's kind of agitated or paranoid
or whatever and it's just all going to
be okay whatever and then you've got
folks who think that the us is
descending into
either fascism or communism or something
like that respectfully essentially right
or left authoritarianism
and they are reacting to that and
they're like oh my god you know and
you're seeing this every single day on
social media people are pushing back
against us and the thing is that
while those two groups
all share
you know they've got huge differences
one thing that is true verbally
rhetorically conceptually cognitively is
even if you know there's left and right
vectors that point like this they're
both pointing anti-authority they're
pointing
against hierarchy and so the left might
say we are all equal and the right might
say you ain't the boss of me
but both of them point towards this kind
of concept of you can't control me
no hierarchy is legitimate
you know i do not trust authority and so
on and so forth right so that's an that
is a subtle vector sum on one axis even
if the left and right cancel the
anti-authoritarian aspect is summing
right does that make sense yeah it makes
sense if that is the case
then it's the thing that is not
conceptualized that we're actually
driving towards the consensus
is for anarchy
because
the left and the right can agree that
the hierarchy is illegitimate in some
way that the institutions are
illegitimate whether it's
institutionally exist or if it is
you know it's all the deep state
both of them are tugging on it in a
certain way where there's a vector sum
towards
taking it apart
and the thing about that is
american anarchy is like the ultimate in
liberty and equality
everybody's equal because there's no
bosses everybody's free because there's
no laws or hierarchy there's an aspect
of this that is the ultimate of
democracy and the ultimate of capitalism
everybody's doing whatever they want
right
and that strain exists in american
culture on kind of both sides there is a
deep liberty you know kind of thing and
then you've got folks who will actually
say anarchy is good and they might say
it as good as anarcho-communism or they
might call say crypto anarchy where
you're you're imposing you know
something like bitcoin on top of it
basically it's like the physical world
is very chaotic but you have a digital
world and digital property rights that
are there for some kind of structure
online but the issue here is we have
sort of seen what the transition to
anarchy looks like in many countries
around the world over the last couple of
decades
there's a book by barbara walter called
how civil war start which you know
there's a lot of things i disagree with
her on but i actually give her credit
for essentially pointing out that many
american interventions and other
interventions overseas nato and you know
other stuff
over the last few decades they've been
in the intent of spreading democracy and
they've caused anarchy like mexico is
way more chaotic than it was ian grillo
has this book called el narco where he
talks about how mexico's democratic
transition
attended this
huge burst in you know the narco
terrorism and violent gangs and so on
and so forth tunisia libya
egypt a bunch of these countries
have essentially we've sort of seen them
go from reasonably okay to kind of an
arctic and there's a playbook for how
that looks
and that's actually if you if you before
and after if you just teleported
somebody from 2005 or 1995 you know 97
essentially today i mean there's always
some you can track it back and be like
well oklahoma city happened in 1995 and
there's a unabomber there's always
something that you can say was a trend
line all the way through but
visual capitalist for example has a
graph of riots and
shootings and bombings and stuff like
that and it's up and to the right
yeah it is it is something where it's
like surged in 2020 and it came back
down but it's rising and it reminds me a
lot of crypto where what happens is it
surges and it crashes and then people
write it off and they're like
it's over
like that crypto thing is done
but it's not done it's coming back and
that surge of anarchy in 2020 that came
down yeah 2021 2022 is more peaceful
than 2020 but it's way more anarchic
than 2017 which is itself more anarchic
than 2012 right so american anarchy is
on the rise and what does that actually
look like there's lots of ways it can
play out
i happen to think it's going to be
something like
maximalist versus wokes in the u.s that
it's going to be something like a broke
i mean there's lots of different
triggers okay this is just a sci-fi
scenario right now i'm just spitballing
but and by maximalist you mean like btc
maximalist so what kind of maximalists
are we talking about yes bitcoin
maximalist versus books
right are there enough bitcoin
maximalists in the us to constitute a
critical mass
for that
so i think bitcoin maximalism is the
most important ideology in the world
that people don't know about
okay and
why do i say that i can hear people
clapping through the silence a lot of
people listening are going to be getting
out of their seats for that one so
please continue
well the thing is that from the outside
people would think i'm a bitcoin
maximalist okay
but it's a log scale
to a truly devout orthodox bitcoin
maximalist i'm a status cuck okay so
because i'm fundamentally like a
pragmatist basically right you're a very
middle of the road crypto anarchist
i'm just kidding well but i'm not a
crypt that's the thing is in this book
i'm actually not a critic no no it's
what you're saying is actually
it's extremely important because
the
so much i could say let me see if i can
download it first is
one of the chapters in the book is
centralization decentralization
recentralization
and the thing is when you say
recentralization
what happens is both the centralized and
decentralized guys look at you like
you've got four eyes the centralized
guys say wait a second we're running
america we're running china the u.s
establishment exists ccp exists
why would you want
re-centralization
we have an operating centralized system
here okay and then the decentralized be
like
why would you want recentralization
we're talking about taking power away
from these totally illegitimate
establishments with bitcoin we're
talking about breaking the state and
defunding the government and so on we're
giving them defunding the police for
defunding everything right and
we're talking about breaking these
tyrannies and getting away from the
surveillance state why would you ever
want to rebuild something like that
right so the thing is that
recentralization has the smallest
constituency right now but i think it's
the right constituency and the reason is
i believe one of the things i point out
in the book is the helical theory of
history
so the linear theory of history is we're
just progressing we're just improving
we're getting more equal we're leveling
up everything's getting better and so
and so there's something to be said for
this on some axes on some measures
humans have been improving like our
knowledge of math for example that is
like a roughly cumulative chart it has
drops when you have the dark ages and
stuff like that it's not all the way up
to it but it's like up into the right
okay then you have the cyclical theory
of history which is
and actually one of the things i talked
about in the book is about the left and
a right and a libertarian cycle of
history but the right cycle of history
is
strong men create good times good times
create weak men weak men create hard
times hard times create strong men where
it's basically like you know this is the
fourth turning right
yeah yeah so it's niche and band of
spartans they go and build a great
society and then these degenerates take
it down and then you know we have to
like from the chaos and ashes rebuild
again and so on right what's funny is
the left has their own version of this
which is
the zealous revolutionaries manage to
fight the man and overthrow it
and then a stalin-like figure comes and
compromises the revolution and the new
boss is the same as the old boss and and
then it comes back to this right and
then the tech libertarian has a version
that's also like this which is the
startup founder goes and rebels against
the bureaucracy they manage to build an
operational thing that is actually much
more egalitarian and it's got a flatter
hierarchy and takes care of all the
bureaucracy and it's actually more
competitive and then what happens is the
bureaucracy encrusts us and the
libertarian founder rebuilds the state
right and one of the points that make is
all three of those cycles are the same
cycle
because
it's not just the right cycle of being
like strong and it's not just the left
cycle of being zealous and it's not just
the libertarian cycle of having an
innovation you kind of need all of those
at the same time to actually go all the
way around the cycle to fight that
establishment so what do you think the
u.s looks like in five years
if we could paint a picture
oh sure
it's
like
blm and jan sixth
all the time
or let's say much more you mean in terms
of events or in terms of discussion in
terms of
like
there will be mobs that are gathered
online there will be it's like
stochastic network warfare between two
groups
that would be uh somebody says five
years might be ten years i don't know
the exact time frame it could happen
faster could happen slower but
fundamentally i think the catalyst is if
you look at interest rates and you look
at the graph have you ever look at look
at like the long-term graph of interest
rates
yeah i have actually but uh we should
put it in the show notes for people we
should put in the show notes i just want
to find this graph long-term chart okay
so if you go to
this graph and you click max
all right so this is trading economics
dot com slash united hyphen states slash
interest
hyphen rate
yeah so united states interest rate
united states fed funds rate trading
economics.com right i'm looking at max
okay and so what do you see you
essentially see something where
over a
40-year time frame
you have like
a trend which is very much down into the
right
yeah yep
and
what that is is it's basically something
where one of the things i write about
and dalio's actually also talked about
this
there are trends that affect humans that
are
longer than the cycles that we're
intuitively familiar with
for example you're familiar with the
cycle of your breath that's a few
seconds right you're familiar with the
day you're familiar with
you know
basically the seasons of a year
and that's actually what most people are
familiar with beyond that maybe the
election cycle you know in four years or
the longest thing somebody might be
familiar with frankly are venture
capital funds or startups which are like
10-year cycles that might be the longest
thing where you can run an experiment
and see a few reps of it
in a five or ten year time frame over
your life right a venture capitalist
might see hundreds or thousands of five
or ten year long experiments that most
people don't really don't really track
things over that time frame and any
normal human cannot really track things
over 40 or 50 years you have to kind of
dedicate your life to that right same
thing that's happening over multiple
decades you really need really good
charts and stuff to see what the heck is
happening this graph is one of the best
and most important because it's so
unambiguous and what it shows is
essentially that the u.s economy
we have run out of
juice
the federal reserve being able to print
money and so on it just keeps going down
on this trend like interest rates and
if you notice every time they try to
jack it up it has to be
pushed back down and kept down for
longer and longer and longer right if
you're seeing that in that graph yeah
and now the next time when they're
they're going to be forced probably
to
bring interest rates all the way to the
floor maybe before the 2024 election and
i think you will see
very serious inflation as a function of
that because they'll print money
and will actually have genuine goods
shortages
because we have all these supply chain
things that are hitting you have china
doing its crazy
stuff with it with the ports and
the the the coveted lockdowns you have
the
do you know the slow steaming
regulations
i do not know the slow steaming
regulations
basically like some esg thing this is a
great example of how like moral
you know the moral flipping
i'm getting the second hand so i might
have it
wrong but
i believe it is
reducing the speed of cargo ships to cut
down carbon emissions right okay let me
just define two things real quickly so
you mentioned dalio just for people who
don't know ray dalio former
let's just call him head principal at
bridgewater associates at least at the
time that i interviewed him largest
hedge fund in the world about 175
billion or something like that esg
environmental social and governance
factors so just that bleeds into the
what you were just discussing so please
continue that's right so just to
summarize it basically we have more
money they'll eventually need to print
again we have literally fewer goods
where china's cutting off supply there's
sanctions there's wars like ukraine
there are
coveted lockdowns
there's stuff like slow steaming which
is this huge self-inflicted wound by the
esg thing where every single container
ship in the world has to slow down now
right so you have
a lot of things that can sum up into
something where it gets non-linear fast
and
if that happens and you do have not just
the inflation we have now but genuine
serious inflation or even hyperinflation
that is when society comes apart in the
u.s because
i mean people have been so freaking
angry at each other during the 2010s in
a relatively booming market
right like in the 2010s up until 2019
things were like decent economically but
man were people mad at each other and
when there's like actual genuine
scarcity if that does happen if physical
goods are hard to come by and your
inflation you know inflation's destroyed
your currency and so on and you have a
country where people are heavily armed
and they're yelling at each other on
social media and you've got 50 governors
like
you've got a very potent cocktail for
bad things and we've sort of seen this
in lots of other countries
that
frankly america was involved in in you
know partially destabilizing like look
at libya or something like that
or mexico or what have you but that
people just really do believe on some
level quote it can't happen here
but i think american anarchy
unfortunately
is is sort of where we're heading
what exactly does that mean you know try
and paint a picture so first of all
in 1861 if you go and look at
the map in 1861 you have the
union and you have the confederates and
it's
the ideological and the geographical
coincide right you have the north and
you have the south and we take for
granted that the victory condition was
for the north to just
invade the south and because by invading
their capital and burning and so on they
didn't just destroy their supply chain
they also killed their morale and
eventually they got the entire south to
concede and they could flip them
ideologically and you know emancipation
proclamation reconstruction they
uninstalled the software in their heads
and installed software with new moral
premises same in world war ii invade
nazi germany denotify them capture the
capital the ideological and geographical
coincided and that's how we think of
wars as working
now
today though if you go and look at a map
of the us and you look at republican
democrat
it's not like in clean states it's very
fractal it's at the individual county
level you've got little red here little
you know blue here purple here it's
extremely
grouped together it's fractal
and so that means is
that in physical space these two nations
are cheek by gel
but in digital space
as a as that graph i showed you show
those two social networks are just
clustered apart in digital space right
they're they're separated in digital
space did i show you that graphic did
you see it yeah i got this one we'll put
this in the show notes for everybody
so when you see that graph you're like
oh okay so in physical space people are
cheeked by gel but in digital space
they're far apart and that's where the
battlefront is right and you can
reconceptualize the last several years
as a social war
okay because if in a physical war the
goal is to invade territory in a social
war the goal is to invade minds
and now when we think about cancellation
d-platforming hashtags etc etc the point
is that
what you're trying to do is get a node
on their side to flip from blue to red
or red to blue and how do you do that
because they're now uttering your
hashtag slogan right blm or mega or
something like that they're uttering
that slogan that node is flipped it's
like capture the flag you're seeing from
their utterance that they are saying the
thing that indicates they're now on your
team right they're raising a flag over
their company etc and
you are able to cancel and silence those
people who are saying things that are
contrary to your view and so on and so
forth it is essentially something where
because you are constrained from using
physical violence
since what are you going to invade a
cornfield in veda city that doesn't
actually work
you're winning digitally it's digital
warfare right now when i say constrained
from using physical violence as we've
seen that's actually less of you know
we're starting to see stochastic digital
violence
the proud boys and antifa and so on
punching it out in the street that's
actually
an extremely unusual thing in the 90s
and 2000s america you just never saw
like left and right wing militias
punching it out in the streets but you
see that now that's actually something
which is
de rigueur i don't know we're on the
100th or 300th it's like it's like an
event you wouldn't be like totally
shocked that that's happening that
political violence is happening in
america but it is
and it's on a ramp
and so you put all that together and
basically what i see is
serious inflation
bitcoin mooning and then the u.s
government trying to freeze or seize the
bitcoin with something that's similar to
executive order 6102
my question for you just quickly on
bitcoin mooning
so
we have not yet seen i don't think in
the charts bitcoin act
as an inflation hedge right in the same
way that say gold perhaps has why would
that be different this time around
so this is not a hundred percent it's
possible that i'm wrong about this but
and i say this as someone who owns quite
a bit of bitcoin
so so here's the fundamentals argument
for that right you know as sometimes
there's certain things where the
correlations only
are visible over the very long run you
know like the interest rate graph we
were just talking about yep in this case
you know we haven't seen a long run of
bitcoin but what we have seen a long run
with is gold
and the fundamental thing is
bitcoin's core value proposition is
seizure
resistance that's to say
all stocks
can be seized by hitting a button
as was done with the truckers the
canadian truckers was done with the
russian sanctions on 145 million people
billions billions you know hundreds of
billions of dollars i think was just
frozen because those assets existed
on servers that the u.s establishment
had root control over and i say the u.s
establishment that's not exactly the us
government there's a government but
there's also the network of people
who are loyal to the u.s establishment
those are
like certain tech ceos or newspaper
publishers and so on it's basically
extended it's all the folks who are
basically supporting the current order
if those folks can hit a key and freeze
your assets you don't really own your
assets in a wartime scenario as what
happened with russia just now the assets
aren't theirs now outside the u.s this
means
this has meant that a lot of countries
are re-examining whether they want to
have so much exposure to things that the
us government has has root access to
powell actually had speech on the
dollar's role and competition just a few
weeks ago where he mentioned stable
coins you can probably find a better
version of this but it's basically
rapid changes are taking place in the
global monetary system that may affect
the international role of dollar a
central bank digital currency is being
examined to help the dollars
international standing so that is
not some random person
that's the chair of the federal reserve
mentioning a that the dollar's
international standing is being called
into question and b
that cryptocurrencies and stable coins
are related to the preservation of that
standing okay
so when you zoom out signal and noise
that's remarkable relative to where
bitcoin was in 2010 10 years later
the federal reserve chair saying the
dollar's role in international finance
is being re-examined and
cryptocurrencies are part of the
mix of policy responses
yeah that actually shows we are whether
you want to call it winning certainly
affecting and changing things right so
the thing is only those assets that
can't be
frozen or seized are your assets
and
bitcoin
has a root system that extends way
outside the united states
to
hundreds of millions of people around
the world that value it
and that is not the case for your frozen
assets on a stock exchange for your
valueless dollars your chair that you
can't move across borders and so on and
so forth
there's a shelling point that has been
built up which is probably going to be
bitcoin now why is it not gold well the
thing is there's either physical gold or
you have
you know some certificate which has
counterparty risk right so if it's a
certificate you're back to square one
where it can be seized and and even with
physical gold executive order 6102
showed that
a sufficiently motivated central
government can defeat gold
we have not yet seen
that bitcoin can be so defeated it is in
question
executive order 6102 for those who don't
know is fdr's gold seizure so the very
organized us government at that time was
able to seize the gold and then resell
it on international markets at a markup
it was just this giant tax on all
americans right and
something like that i think is quite
likely to happen because it just takes
all the rhetoric on abolish billionaires
tax these rich guys blah blah blah all
that type of stuff which is
people won't care that someone took on
risk to to invest in bitcoin or hold
bitcoin during the drawdown they won't
care about any of that they will care if
bitcoin is a million dollars and the
dollar is inflated and it's 2027 or 2028
and you need this to fund the us
government
i know that sounds crazy but think about
it like this
in 2010
there are people who had seen the arab
spring and they'd seen how important
social media was abroad
if nevertheless having seen that you
projected that by 2020 or 2021 the most
important political issue in the world
would be whether the president could
tweet
for a time period right that literally
one bit flip
on a server in virginia
that you remember the thing we're
talking about with mimesis and what
people fight about 5440 or fight right
this account like the bytes on this
server in virginia okay when i say
virginia's probably amazon's servers
there that twitter is hosted on
the bytes on that server those little
bytes that record what somebody was
saying
that's where the fight is
whether this person can or cannot tweet
is literally a matter like
billions of people around the world
wanted to know whether that bit would
flip this way or that way
okay that's insane from the perspective
of 2010 even knowing
that twitter and facebook had done the
arab spring that they caused social
revolutions abroad that they had
connected hundreds of millions of people
if you had written that the entire
politics of the world would depend on
whether the united states president
could tweet
it would be an extrapolation but that's
what i'm trying to tell you is i do
think that if in the 2010s social media
became what all politics is about
by the end of the 2020s cryptocurrency
becomes what all politics is about you
will not be able to fund your government
without it all right let me let me hop
in here so there are three things that
i'd i'd really love to cover and
we'll we'll see if we can do it
uh so the the first just because i don't
want to let this go too quickly because
i know it's a question that is on a lot
of people's minds
so you're painting a picture for
bitcoin
appreciating in value based on
the difficulty in seizing bitcoin by a
central actor like
a government
now
many people right not not your keys not
your crypto will have their crypto in uh
trusted third parties
and will not have
cold storage and be going through all
the jason bourne steps necessary to sort
of implement all of that well right or
they'll do it in a b minus fashion and
it'll all be trackable anyway so if they
throw you in a jail cell you're going to
give up your keys probably
but my
questions are so i want to i do want to
make sure we hone in on like if you had
to bet on what the first extremely
important question yeah so let me just
lay out my kind of menu my wish list
here and we can we might tackle it in
reverse order but the first successful
network state what does it look like
right that that i would love to hear
your answer to
then you have bitcoin maximism is the
most important ideology no one has heard
of i want to double click on that and
understand why that's the case and then
coming back to the most recent
conversation we've been having what
would need to change for bitcoin to
actually behave from a pricing
perspective as an inflation hedge
because it is seemed to be
up to this point
a risk on asset with instant liquidity
in a market that never closes and when
[ __ ] goes sideways or people get afraid
there's a sell-off so it doesn't seem to
mirror
the
behavior of say gold in the perhaps
traditional way that some investors view
it as an inflation hedge or hedge of
other types and so so i'm just wondering
if if a lot of people who participate
crypto are not going to have
cold wallets
and therefore not a critical mass
perhaps enough of a critical mass to
move the market and again there's a lot
of assumptions baked into this question
but
what would need to change for bitcoin to
suddenly
behave in the way that you are
describing is it the international
devaluing
and when i say devalue i mean more
perceptually of
non-us governments and central banks and
so on with respect to the u.s dollar but
even if that happens i kind of fail to
see how that makes the hop so could you
just paint a picture of
what needs to happen for for bitcoin to
behave in the way that bitcoin holders
would like it to behave well see here's
the thing is the reason i'm not a
maximalist is
i
many reasons
but one of them is i don't think
everything can be reduced to money i
actually think maximus often in some
ways
sort of how
wokes are like the opposite of nazis you
know they're both racially obsessed but
they like white people are the best
white people are the worst but you get a
lot of the same things like separate
graduations and all this stuff
maximums are like the opposite of
communists in the sense that they're
both economically obsessed and the
communists thinks everything is
you know
should be within the state and it's the
fault of business and the maximus is
actually often the opposite and the
issue is why am i not a maximum as well
for example
there's many things you can't just buy
like if you're in syria and you have 100
btc what do you actually want to buy you
want to buy peace
right you want to buy a walk down the
street in a high trust neighborhood
where there aren't bombs flying around
biology just for people who don't have
the definition could you define what a
what is a bitcoin maximalist what is
that ideology or that belief system
there's different definitions
but i would define it as
somebody who thinks that any digital
asset other than bitcoin is a sin
got it okay
and it is
you know people have made the comparison
of like wokeness to a religion in my
book i actually talked about it as a
doctrine
which is
related to religion but not exactly the
same more than a technicality the wokes
they actually don't worship god they
worship the state and or the network
that's to say they're not about thoughts
and prayers they're about pass a law and
they're not all employed by the state
they're outside of it and they act
through it on a network right
maximalists are similar in that they've
got the zeal of a monotheist
or of a monostatist like a communist but
they're a mono-numist for a coin you
know so
and and and one of the things that's
interesting is you know like a communist
would be
pathologizing profit and a christian
fundamentalist or religious
fundamentalist would pathologize
interest
and a maximalist pathologizes
digital issuance
so just to kind of click on that right
like a communist
they think of all profit as exploitative
that boss is obviously screwing somebody
because you know he did a markup didn't
he why couldn't he give it away for free
to the community he's stealing some for
himself like there's a 50 arguments you
can make against this but the problem is
that it's intuitively appealing to
people that profit is sort of getting
one over on somebody right it feels like
a scam right and communists were able to
get hundreds of millions of people to
buy into this notion and it was it was
something where rather than say look
there's good profit and bad profit and
manage this they just pathologize the
whole thing interest is similar
you know christian fundamentalists other
religious fundamentalists there's things
about missouri's interest rates are you
familiar with this concept like user
yeah usury yep i am so what was the
concept is basically like
they take the good and true thing that
debt is bad and i would actually also
agree that most americans are in way
more debt than they're supposed to be
or should be and it's like a power tool
they take the valid concept that
interest can be abused is being abused
has been abused and they turn it into
something which says interest cannot
happen okay but if interest cannot
happen and interest is banned and
because all interest is usury
you break the economy yeah and let me
just hop in for a second so usury i'm
just going to give a definition here the
illegal action or practice of lending
money at unreasonably high rates of
interest
yeah and everything is in unreasonably
yeah everything is unreasonably right so
if
anyway we get into what that means but
yes yeah exactly yes so because any rate
of interest
is unreasonable in in some under some
religions like you know
islamic finance for example or
like very religious christian you know
groups were against interest of any kind
at all right
then what happens is every single
financial model breaks you cannot figure
out okay should i allocate money into
this building project or this tech like
basically the power user tool goes goes
away you might say and i might agree
with you that the average joe should not
be buying all the stuff on credit and
debt and they're getting screwed by it
and i might agree with you on that but i
don't think you can take away the power
tool because it just breaks the economy
and then we go to issuance right if the
communist pathologize profit and the
fundamentalist pathologizes interest the
maximalist pathologizes digital issuance
they're okay with the issuance of equity
paper equity
that's to say you know you can go and
incorporate a company and pre-mine
the shares the company for the founders
that's like an accepted thing to do
every single company is like that you
know you're pre-mining the shares oh my
god and
the thing is that you get people to buy
into it or not um and it's your own
efforts why do you issue that new
currency why do you have that stock why
doesn't everybody just get paid dollars
in your company why is it not all
dollars why why equity equity is a scam
right like that's what
you know lots of folks on hacker news
will say they'll say all startup equity
market is zero it doesn't it's not worth
it well the reason is that if again
going back to first principles the value
of an equity uh or stock is the net
present value of
you know the future dividends that would
go to that share and so you know
basically you buy a stock and then you
assume that in 10 years or 15 years
facebook goes public and it pays out
dividends and you pay ten dollars down
you get you know
fifty dollars in dividends in in 15
years and that's actually that's a win
right now of course in practice
for tax reasons other reasons companies
will do buybacks and there's lots of
ways where that
econ 101 or micro econ 101 cons of the
dividend has been abused granting all
that but fundamentally there is an
income stream there and the reason that
you don't just have somebody
just give dollars to everybody at a
company is that through their efforts
they can go and close sales they can
close deals you can go close the sale
for 10 million dollars that brings in
revenue into the company in theory that
could be dividended out
to the shareholders and therefore your
individual efforts can boost the value
of that equity in a way that you cannot
really boost the value of the dollar
right yeah like your your elasticity
right you're not you know the dollar
economy is so massive that your
individual efforts will be a drop in the
bucket relative to a million other
people who are doing things right so
your effort results in results right
effort and results that's capitalism
that's the thing that
deng xiaoping's key insight the reason
that china boomed as he allowed the
farmers to keep some of their green that
their effort led to results right so
effortless results that's what equity is
it gives you a shot i know i'm
explaining like super basic things but
honestly
this community has gotten its head into
this sort of religious fundamentalist
mode this community meaning btc
maximalism maximalist yeah because
they've gone their head into a religious
fundamentalist mode where and and by the
way some of the faultier lies of the sec
as well fundamentally
we have not been able to make the
analogy between digital equity and paper
equity why because
the sec
has tried to say oh they're all
unregistered securities and so we're
going to throw everybody in jail and so
on and so forth so what does that mean
that means that
look do i think that a digital asset is
the same as an equity no i think it's
like
a horseless carriage
versus
a a horse-drawn carriage at first you
make the analogy but it's also got
fundamental differences
you know with a digital asset you can
you can issue it to all of your users
they can use it in programs it's on
chain it does all it slices it does it
does tons of things a paper equity does
not right
but it is similar in one sense which is
that a paper equity is something that
incentivizes people to build out a
company and a digital asset incentivizes
people to build out a network right now
the problem is that the sec you've got a
pincer attack of the journalists and the
maximalist basically okay the
bureaucrats and the maximalists because
on the one side you have these guys who
are stuck in the past with orange groves
and howie that are they're the sec guys
who are trying to
pathologize
the issuance of digital assets and
saying ah we're gonna go after that
that's like unregulated you know
issuance of of assets and the crucial
thing by the way is they're not like
going after the bad actors in the space
they're going after for example they
went after kik you know which is uh
like a fairly reputable
company they just randomly targeted them
for enforcement they're just going after
not the bad actors the actors they can
get the maximum headlines on
what that does is it forces web3 people
to not make the analogy to equity
when they can't make the analogy to
equity
and they have to like shy away from it
with all kinds of stupid word games and
so on and so forth people do get the
sense oh there's something up here
they're not being totally
straightforward with me and then that
pushes it it's like this trampolining
and then the maximus attack it as haha
it's actually equity in disguise like an
illegal crowdfunding or whatever and the
thing is that same maximalist is
typically
anti-fed
yet pro-sec right they're like the most
selective crypto anarchist ever where
you know you're you're against the
federal reserve you know what i'm saying
for the discerning crypto anarchist yeah
yeah
i don't often engage in crypto anarchy
but when i do yeah yes and the thing is
it is fundamentally in a sense
unprincipled right it is basically
something where it's like
there is a rationale for it which is
number go up technology like anything
that seems to make the price of bitcoin
goes up is good and if that means
banning every other coins the only coin
people can buy is bitcoin well that's
good again though this is like the
communist zero sum mentality because if
the web 3 crypto economy didn't exist i
don't believe that bitcoin would be
where it is you need all of this
infrastructure around it to build a
thing up i think that's super obvious
yeah you need more cultural awareness
you need the zeitgeist to shift like all
these all of these things or a lot of
them contribute to the rise of bitcoin
also indirectly yeah yeah i mean it's
like it's like to me that's
insanely obvious but the thing is that
the 21 million
again there's an aspect of it that zero
sum like the communist which is one
person's gains another person's loss if
you're getting bitcoin i must be losing
bitcoin one of the ways you see this is
in the bitcoin community you don't see
that many crowdfunders you see actually
fairly large crowdfunders in ethereum
and so on right now
what does the maximus community have you
know like i've i've criticized it but
let me actually say certain things that
i mean
it's very complicated because
maximalism
has
it's right way of putting this
many of the things that they say
are things where i agree with
some or all of it
but it reminds me of
it's like somebody who's a progressive
and they would agree with many
statements about how
you need to have equity and you know not
discriminate against people and so on
but then they see people saying those
things going and burning down black
businesses
and that's like completely the opposite
of what you actually seem to want
ideologically right this is harming
these people that you're claiming to
help right so the words
don't match the actions necessarily you
know if the words are in this case for
greater freedom and so on why are you
arguing for like governments to crack
down why are you arguing for
willing buyer willing seller to stop why
are you trying to pathologize capitalism
that doesn't seem to make any sense
right and that's because i think it's
gotten
sort of maximalism gun twisted in this
ideological knot
which unfortunately is going to be very
helpful
and that's that that's the paradox
you're like what that's an unusual
here's the thing
i know i'm digressing but let me i'll
bring it i'll bring it home i'll bring
it home okay yeah and then i also want
to hear what bitcoin would need to do or
what would need to happen
or what will happen to make bitcoin
behave in the way that so many holders
such as myself would like it to behave
totally terms
so the answer is one of the things i've
learned over the last 10 years 15 years
is the value of irrationality
all the other people in web3 basically
are in our inner technology or finance
or something like that right maximalists
are in it for fundamentally political
slash moral social
ethical kind of things do i
i think there's a continuum where as i
said
some of the words i agree with but a lot
of the actions and behavior i don't
still i recognize the zeal
and zeal really really really matters
zeal matters because
zeal is the difference between selling
when it's low and zeal's difference
between selling never
zeal is the difference between talking
to everybody about it all the time and
making it your life and just having it
be one component of a otherwise healthy
life zeal means putting it at the top of
your identity stack putting it in your
profile having it be part of your
existence like you know the top of your
identity sack that's really precious
space you know what you identify
yourself as
you know you might live in missouri but
you're not might not identify yourself
as a missourian you might identify
yourself as as a bitcoiner or as a
christian or as a republican or
something that top identity thing is
really important and that's something
that max must have and so what i think
is actually going to happen is the
political spectrum will rotate i think
imagine adding yellow a splash of yellow
so that red blue becomes orange versus
green
okay and orange versus green rotates it
and so it's bitcoin orange versus dollar
green
and on the dollar green side are
actually quite a few republicans
a lot of the you know security state
people military people neocons folks who
basically side with at the end of the
day they will choose the american flag
and they'll choose the the us government
and so on and the other side is bitcoin
orange and here actually lots of
democrats will actually choose this side
and for example like jack dorsey like
glenn greenwald like
a lot of the sub stackers like a lot of
the tech founders
these are folks who would never you know
fold into trump but they also are just
fundamentally anti-establishment they
have that rebel dna that fundamental
rebel dna just like a lot of those
republicans who will side with dollar
green
don't really like the current us
government but fundamentally it's my
country right or wrong okay so it's a
rotation
of the spectrum
you know if the normal political
spectrum is left versus right this is
like top versus bottom it's like the
authoritarian
is dollar green and the libertarian is
bitcoin orange okay
and that rotation
is a pretty big shift uh you know i'm
not sure what percentage of both parties
shift it might be that
orange is like 60 republican and 40
democrat swimming but one of the most
underappreciated aspects is many many
non-white people will shift to bitcoin
orange and the reason is is that
inflation hits
like african-americans latinos asians
and whites all at the same you know and
if you look the more
equities and other assets you hold
in some ways you're kind of more
buffered from this at least you can have
some ups as well some downs but
inflation is absolutely crushing
people of color
and that is something i think you know
for example jack dorsey who has square
cash
that's actually very popular
among the african american community
among other communities and it has a
different
user base than your typical like tech
app and in fact he's
gone and and talked about that given
talks about that and tweets about that
and so he's probably seeing this in the
numbers that inflation is hitting this
group harder so because of that
the moral legitimacy of the
establishment is called into question
because they define themselves if you
read again like something like barbara
walters book or something she imagines
that this future civil war or conflict
will be between a
tolerant diverse establishment and some
like 4chan nazis
right
but that's a wash that's that's an easy
win that's a 90 10 win right that's 95
99 1 or whatever right
when you rotate it and instead it is
basically all
pro freedom people
who are bitcoin orange and against
inflation and probably maybe more people
of color than not than on the other side
and then you have
well it's still our flag it's still our
country it's still our state
that's now set up for something that's
much closer to a 50 50. right that's
actually something where a lot of people
would be torn between those two groups
you know and when it's 50 50
unfortunately that's when conflict is
maximum
so that unfortunately is how i
anticipate things to go
when do you think digital gold will
behave like gold
if ever great question all right so now
let's talk about that so practicalities
these practicalities really matter why
do they matter well the question of
whether twitter could censor somebody's
account and so on was an abstraction
because people just assumed that
you know they wouldn't hit it you should
assume every single thing gets
weaponized in crazy ways we have not yet
had total cyber war we're going to see
some crazy things as a function of that
and that's going to push people to truly
not your keys not your coins type stuff
problem is right now
yes a lot of coins are on exchanges
what i think we're going to see is
every possible edge case and failure
mode will happen
but
maximalism is not simply a technological
thing really it's mostly a political
thing now okay so first what are all the
things that will happen okay i think you
will see
freeze and seizure orders given to
centralized exchanges
they may have however
the moral
support from their community to not
comply
they may be located in red states
where the governor says this is a
sanctuary state for crypto
because if you think about the concept
of a sanctuary state for immigration or
for abortion or for gun laws right
all of that groundwork has already been
laid
right one of the things i predict in the
book i talk about is i think that
maximalist will introduce a
constitutional amendment
for
no seizures of bitcoin just like free
speech or you know right to bear arms
can't seize bitcoin
fundamental right
and i actually think you'll probably be
able to get that through in a fair
number of u.s states maybe not the full
constitutional amendment ratification
process like you may not get like the
quorum that's necessary but i think
you'll get that ratified in some states
and then those states that are ratified
it can point to that and say we've
ratified it therefore it's the law of
our state therefore we're not seizing
the bitcoin and companies could put
their servers there
okay i mean this is the level that i
think things are going to get you
they're going to get really intense or
they keep them in el salvador right or
they keep them somewhere else and then
the question is you know like the andrew
jackson thing the court has made its
judgment let them enforce it
okay
so just like i said like you know in
2010 would it have seemed insane
to say that the billions of people would
care about the position of some bytes on
a server in virginia where
trump has access to tweet or not you
know like that would be insane
i'm telling you people are gonna really
care
where that money is in five or ten years
they're really going to care you know if
they can freeze it or not yeah now a few
other things that can hit quantum
computing could hit okay it is possible
that the chinese who are working heavily
this
this is the thing about the book i talk
about there's so many different billiard
balls in this
theater it's like a world war in the
sense of there's all these different
theaters happening and you could just be
absorbed with the american theater but
there's like the asian theater and
there's this theater and there's that
theater you know
so the chinese are working very
aggressively on quantum and there's a
scenario i'm not an expert in in quantum
computing i know enough to be dangerous
but there's a scenario where quantum
decryption
advances
fast enough and quantum encryption isn't
there or it's expensive and you can do
decryption with these you know high
qubit systems that are in one location
but encryption you can't do outside or
something like that quantum safe
algorithms just don't get distributed in
time
i've seen people argue about this i'm
not saying i'm strongly on one side or
the other but that's like a wild card
that could come through that breaks some
of the assumptions on the cryptography
there's other attacks that could happen
firewall attacks where you try to block
the packets they're going through and
then the people pipe them over starlink
or they try to do
you know port randomization or they try
to encrypt the traffic so it looks like
in so you're saying an email when you're
sending a bitcoin transaction
people could try
oh my there's so many things people try
one of the issues is the bitcoin network
itself is not extremely high capacity
for on-chain transactions so
it's hard for everybody to use it on
chain all the time but people can go and
hold large amounts of money with one
transaction i am seeing stats which show
coins coming off exchanges
since
i think early 2020 or thereabouts i am
seeing those numbers i think glass node
has some of those numbers so you can see
i think a decline in this why because
actually you know in the funny things
it's hilarious it's actually
pulling money off of exchanges you know
what it is
i do not
defy d5 defy
because you can only engage with it
through like a decentralized wallet for
the most part i mean there are
centralized exchanges let you do it but
regulations make it hard
because of that people have moved funds
more and more funds locally there's been
a financial incentive to pull funds
locally and that i mean incentives
ultimately are work so it's a funny
thing where defy
me actually the thing that lots of
maximalist hate may actually have pulled
more funds okay that's a hypothesis but
i think it'll be the unknowing avenging
angel for the entire sector is this
demonized decentralized defense yeah
yeah yeah exactly and sometimes things
are like that you know
so i i i can't prove it but uh
my my strong hunch is people will bring
the btc locally they will transform it
into something like
wbtc or ren btc or something like that
in a d5 thing and then do something with
it right that's there's several
different operations that are that are
like that i don't have
probably somebody like dune or
nansen or something could support my
hypothesis shoot me down or confirm it
anyway coming back up so the thing is
the bitcoin seizure resistance point
there's many holes in the story in the
sense that there's many things that
people can and will press on from
central exchange seizures to lower
capacity on the chain and whatnot
but the pushback to that and this is the
kind of an important and subtle thing
i'll try to articulate it
when you have
the state coming after you you can
double down on the network okay meaning
internet type technologies but also a
peer-to-peer network of people and so on
and you can do things like zcash which
encrypts all transactions you can do
digital nomadism you can move overseas
you could do you can do all these run
and escape and exit things and those can
be good but it's a tactic and ultimately
you can't just only exit sometimes what
you're doing is you're exiting with a
tactical retreat and you then get to
higher ground you get to a more secure
position then you can push forward right
like you know
the puritans made it all the way to the
u.s and escape persecution and then 170
years later the us the power they built
up they were able to invade europe
or google they escaped this corner which
is search and they built up their
resources there and then they had
billions of dollars they could invade
microsoft's territory with google docs
right sometimes you retreat to a corner
you fight hard enough so that
you're not
being invaded yourself you build up
power there and then you can come back
right that's kind of what the
maximalists have done though not super
conscious necessarily maybe some of them
are conscious fundamentally their
innovation lots of everybody else is
thinking zero knowledge and all this
stuff you know and i think that's good
that's the network innovation the
maximalists are actually
taking some of the state's playbook and
using it so
the el salvador thing
various bitcoin bills
their innovation is actually on the
political level
not technological
they're basically like a quote political
party but really a political network
okay in this sense they're like the
wokes the wokes exist
really as a network thing they exist in
academia and so on they're like a ghost
that can animate a democrat sometimes
and make them do something
sorry that's good yeah i like the image
the image right and here's here's why i
see that like if you look at hillary
clinton or joe biden and you look at
what they were saying in the 90s or 70s
or something like they're saying
completely different things right
these are in a sense a politician is
like inhabited by a ghost that speaks
through them
in fact a lot of things this is actually
a very powerful model for thinking about
a lot of things ideologies are like
ghosts that occupy a huge number of
hosts and then they like animate them
and their eyes glow a certain color to
fight each other
and
often you know for example like russia
versus germany
in
the 1940s we think of that as you know
communism versus nazism
but
now it's like flipped and the germans
are liberals and the russians are
nationalists but they're still fighting
so the ideologies flipped but the tribes
are like still fighting and sometimes
you know one tribe picks left hack as
their tribe picks right tactics and
then you know it flips and one tribe's
picking right taxes are tribes picking
left tactics point is
this concept of like a ghost that's like
inhabiting a politician is also
happening with maximalism
for example
the guy who's running against jd vance
in ohio
josh mandel right
did you see his like tweets on bitcoin
i assure you i have not
okay see the thing is this is the kind
of stuff i track and the reason i track
it is because that's why we're friends
that's why i can have you on the podcast
than i can ask you
yeah so he like sort of casually tweeted
something which was like gosh uh mandel
was like ohio must be pro god pro family
and pro bitcoin right
and the thing is that
look as i said i think bitcoin will
draw significant support from
the working-class democrats
to
because of the inflation thing i mean
the fundamental thing about that is
it doesn't matter what the establishment
says how good their propaganda is when
you're seeing your money
crumble underneath right in fact the
more they say it's transitory the more
they say things like you know one of the
things that's going to be a big message
unfortunately censorship is going to
increase dramatically if inflation
happens do you know why
tell me
because in argentina in other countries
where inflation has happened
the government argues that talking about
inflation causes it
because
you're causing people's price
expectations to rise therefore you're
disloyal
if you talk about inflation and you're
undercutting the stability of our
society
and so therefore they publish public
inflation stats that are fake
and then you have to actually have stats
outside of argentina that are real
and so now we are faced with the issue
of you know like that's that's something
which you know in the 2000s or whatever
you could tut at argentina banana
republic blah blah blah you know
once you need shadow stats that can have
to sit outside not argentina but outside
america right shadow stats on inflation
that are powerful enough to resist
attempted censorship by the us
government i actually wrote this post
last year
with the spec on this at 1729.com front
session inflation that actually goes
through the whole problem which actually
quite a non-trivial problem because you
need censorship-resistant hosting you
need to scrape lots of prices
you need to um have maybe some
instrument that is like an actual not a
stable coin but a flat coin that is
you're tracking oranges you're tracking
bread you're tracking milk and you've
got a coin that remains flat against
those things that's what actually people
care about maintaining their purchasing
power not so much you know whether it's
flat versus a dollar that's inflating
away right
and that post actually it integrates it
takes everything that we've been doing
in crypto and puts into one thing it's
the it's the price signals like all the
price feeds is the decentralized hosting
because states will try to take it down
it is obviously bitcoin but it's also
ethereum with the dapps blah blah blah
it's all it's crypto oracles it's
everything into one app which is the
inflation app that i think becomes like
the new coin market cap it's like the
thing people refresh every single day
that mainstream's kind of web 3 and btc
right i know that sounds like oh my god
that's terrible right and
there are bad aspects to it no no
question about it
one of the things that i'm talking about
with this book is anticipating that
level of instability
what do we build on the other side okay
okay can we actually pause for one
second yes i'm gonna share you've been
sharing
while we're talking we've been sharing
things in the chat i'll share one that
you might enjoy
uh and we don't need to spend a lot of
time on this but you'll you'll probably
enjoy it
so this is a post i put up in
january 2021 and it's a picture of the
reserve bank of zimbabwe with a 100
trillion dollar
note and
in the description i just say had it
framed years ago to remind me of how
quickly quote unquote money can change
in value and
then went into discussion of ultra
inflation and the belief that some
people have of that can't happen to a
reserve currency and on and on and on so
i'll include that in the show notes
what do you think one of the first
successful
attempts at a network state will look
like and related to that because you
mentioned the carbs good carbs bad as as
one possible decision to be made that is
woven into the fabric of a network state
just as an example yes and i'm wondering
how you
how you preserve if this is important
sort of rational adaptability
in the face of new evidence right
because evidence could come out ah turns
out
carbs are good right or whatever it
might be insanely important and so how
do you prevent you know wild wild
country and some
sort of disintegration
into and not disintegration but the
formation of a calcified
religious state
when setting the parameters for a
network state so what is a first what
might a successful network state look
like what would you wager
and how do you prevent the calcification
that i mentioned but you were going to
say something else with respect to the
zimbabwean hundred trillion dollar note
yeah so when there's people who say oh
the reserve currency can't fail and so
on and so forth
they're actually like the inverse of the
maximalist they you're not having a
rational argument with them you're
having an argument about faith and the
reason is one of the chapters or
subsections in the book is i call it god
state network okay the question is
what is the most powerful force in the
world
is it an almighty god
is it the us military is it the
government
or is it encryption
and you know
in the past you might have said
capitalism peer-to-peer networks and so
on okay
god state network the thing is it's a
generalization of religion
religions worship a god okay but a
doctrine if you look at that in the
dictionary it could be a political or
religious or other movement a doctrine
you
you know you have as your leviathan it
could be a god it could be the state or
it could be a network right so communism
is not a religion but it's a doctrine
because they worship a state right
maximal is not a religion but it's a
doctrine because they worship a network
wokeness is sort of like partially state
partially network where they live on the
network but they animate the state okay
communism was actually also partially
state partially networked because they
had this international network of
communists but they were primarily state
the mid-century u.s for example was like
half god half state because it's like
forgotten country will fight the godless
communists right but it was like mostly
state but with a god you know dosing so
you can make hybrids not just pure forms
but
god's state network is actually a really
useful lens to start looking at
movements because the reason that guy is
saying to you that the reserve currency
can never go away is he worships the us
government in a sense even if he doesn't
understand it he really thinks it can
never go away right you know there's
this series of books or a series of
essays
when communism didn't work out and it
was called the god that failed
people put
religious level faith into that right
you know people you probably heard the
term america's civic religion yeah the
constitution as similar to the bible
right and so one of the issues is that
those people who are really asserting
that the reserve currency won't fail
are often the ones who kind of suspect
on some level that maybe it could
and they you know they just can't
imagine a world without that and they
don't want you to undermine their god
right and you're kind of a traitor or
you're like unpatriotic and so on and so
forth and uh you know you sometimes you
talk to somebody's very religious
they'll say well if you didn't believe
in god
people just commit all kinds of crimes
and so on right there's actually by the
way there's there's more argument for
that than you might think because if you
actually believe in hellfire then it's
like decentralized law enforcement you
know the law might only catch you at
some probability but if you actually
believe in hell then
doing this little crime even if the law
doesn't see you well you're going to
hell and that's more of a penalty than
the it's like scalable law enforcement
if you can get people to really believe
in it right it's actually like a metal
logic to it but okay people who don't
believe in god where they believe in
they believe in the boys in blue they
believe in the state okay what if you
don't believe in either you're not just
an atheist but you're an a sadist then
you believe in the network then you end
up in something like maximalism or
crypto tribalism
okay so the thing is that that dispute
i mean there you know carl schmidt wrote
this book called political theology
right and he's like all these religions
i mean he himself was like a nazi jurist
or whatever right so but basically
nazism communism etc these are all you
know many people have observed these are
all effectively like religions
they're either religions themselves or
they're god replacements
and they animate huge numbers of people
to fight as if a religious kind of thing
so therefore we're not just having like
a
a scientific discussion
right it's like a fundamentally
religious discussion just something that
one should think about when you're happy
when you're talking about this kind of
thing there's some folks who look at it
dispassionately and why would you be
able to look at it dispassionately it's
because you may not realize this you
have some island of stability on your
own you're either you had this great
phrase before you're like a tech enabled
jason bourne and actually i thought
about after i'm like that's much more
you than me i'm not going to be doing
all the stunts in the movies in the same
way that tim ferriss is right but the
thing is if you have very high
sense of agency if you're like a ceo or
you're a founder or your president or
you're
like very driven and so on then you can
kind of find your footing on something
you kind of you know you're not a joiner
of a movement but if you need to have if
you don't feel like that and most people
don't for lots of good reason you need
to have a movement that kind of supports
you in some way where you know you can't
just create one from scratch
and that's actually one of the things i
want to help build so that brings me to
your next question basically if it's not
these ideologies of conflict right
because in an era where everything is is
cracking people like these ideologies
these ghosts are set up to recruit
they're set up to pull you in and you're
like you know for example if you were if
you were unfortunate enough to be in
eastern europe
between 1939 to 1945 right
like all these guys had to choose
between the nazis and the communists
that is an absolutely horrible
you know the answer is neither like the
answer is gtfo right good both those are
dead ideologies you know on the ashy
what are you gonna say no just for
people get the [ __ ] out is what that
stands for exactly right and it's true
like those people who were caught in
between that vice
nobody ended up
well off right and and so there's this
false it's like the iran-iraq war
like who wants to be in the middle of
that that's like shiite versus sunni my
answer is neither i do not want to be
involved in this this false dichotomy
this giant conflict david hines had a
had a good thread which i quote on this
which is like
you know what political violence is
actually like
basically
the i'm just going to quote this at
length it's from like seven years ago no
i said five years ago he was like
people have a fantasy of how political
violence works you smite your enemies in
a grand and glorious cleansing because
of course you're better
but grand and glorious smiting isn't
actually how violence works
i'm not sure how to really describe it
so people get it
but this is a stupid comparison but here
imagine that one day godzilla walks
through your town the next day he does
it again and he keeps doing it some days
he steps on more people than others
that's it that's all he does trudging
through your town back and forth your
town's not your town now it's a godzilla
trudging zone that's kind of what it's
like right
and
that
is
i mean if you think about blm or you
know like a giant riot it's not like
some surgical
you know kind of thing it's just like
burning things down blowing things up
it's in the name of some higher cause
that's why people do it but it's
extremely non-targeted it is simply you
know that's why friendly fire happens
where it's like people get blown up
people get blown smoothies immense
damage and destruction on both sides war
really really sucks and
i know that's super obvious to say but
all the wars that you know with the
exception of the military
class that's actually gone overseas and
fought
the u.s
like hasn't actually had experience with
that in living memory you know it's it's
got all these violent video games you
know i like some of these games and so
on but it's all fantasy type stuff and
it's it's not like a reality and once
you actually live through that in world
war ii or the korean war or something
you don't want any more of it and you go
back to like kind of a peace mode you
understand
you understand how things can spiral in
a bad way right
but having had that go for 70 years
people are now being drawn to these
ideologies of conflict
and what is the alternative right so
the thing is and this is i think one of
the more important concepts in the book
these abstractions i pulled out one of
the concepts i have there is the one
commandment
okay so i mentioned god's state and
network and how you can make hybrids of
them right so the network state actually
requires a one commandment so you
actually have something that's like it's
not just uh technology and politics but
something that's similar to faith okay
so what do i mean by one commandment i
mean you take society at large
and you have one
focused moral innovation
relative to society at large
and then you have an opt-in startup
society it could you know it could
literally be
you buy some
land in rural pennsylvania or minnesota
it could start as a digital community
that crowdfunds land around the world
okay so it could start digitally it
could start physically i recommend
starting digitally for a variety of
reasons but you have this community
where you have a moral premise okay
let's say
i give us several examples but there's
different tiers of how aggressive that
moral premise can be it could be
something like cancellation is bad okay
cancel culture is bad so that's
something that you could do purely
online how do you do it purely online
you form a guild where people are there
and they're helping each other out in in
just some general work matters
but if one of them is cancelled at one
point which is a rare event that group
all defends them as one
okay so that's something there's a moral
innovation relative to society at large
where slightly large is sort of neutral
to negative on cancellation but isn't
actually able to stop it this group
actually says that is a danger to our
life
it's a big enough deal that i'm going to
join a society that's like an
anti-cancellation society i'm going to
pay some percentage of my income
effectively in cancellation insurance by
being part of this society i have a
thousand people and i will work with
them on just normal fun stuff 99 the
time will just share each other's
content launch each other's products
advise each other one percent of the
time will have to defend each other
online and it's like a guilt okay
so that moral innovation crucially that
group is not saying change the traffic
laws they're not saying change
everything else they're just innovating
on one focused dimension it's very
similar to a startup right startup is
all about focus one thing you're
changing right um let me give a second
example the one commandment carbs bad
okay
so this is something if the first you
you would need what i call a network
union like a digital only thing
carb is bad you need actually some
physical component you need what i call
a network archipelago so you've got like
a physical network of spaces it could be
like small cul-de-sacs or gyms things
that your community is crowdfunded
around the world and what do you do with
the moral premise carbs bad that moral
innovation
well you basically implement like
keto kosher at the border you have you
introduce it you take it seriously okay
and if you really seriously take sugar
and carbs bad and you take that to the
nth power okay and you have a small town
okay that really thinks sugar is bad
what happens well first of all it
changes everything on the store shelves
okay like every every single grocery
store there's no cookies there's no
[Music]
you know candies there's also no high
fructose corn syrup stuff a lot of the
prepared stuff a lot of that stuff goes
away it changes every restaurant they
can no longer add syrups and things to
their food to make it tastier
it changes every meal so first of all
you basically that alone is a lot right
changing every single meal and every
single grocery store and every
restaurant within these borders is a
pretty big deal as i said keto kosher
there's a precedent for it which is
kosher like a changing food but that's
pretty big you go further once you've
got this done probably people lose like
30 pounds coming to the community so you
have photos that show before and after
that your moral innovation
led to a technological innovation okay
progress used to be thought of as moral
and technological progress together
for example the public health innovators
in the early 1900s
public sanitation like sewers okay that
was
both you know cleanliness is next to
godliness
and it was obviously a technological
innovation for all the pipes and stuff
right but the will came first and then
the way you know those things were
actually like highly related then what
happened is those split over the course
of the 20th century and so now you have
the tech innovators over here who do
startups and stuff then you have the
moral innovators who are political
activists social entrepreneurs and so on
and so forth and we we don't usually
think of those as the same kind of thing
but actually there's a market for
revolutionaries so on on the tech side
it's obvious you have venture
capitalists and you have founders you
know it looks like on the political side
tell me
it looks like activists and
philanthropists
okay so you have activists on right and
left and you have philanthropists on
right and left who are backing these
activists and those activists can be
activist activists they could be
aspiring young politicians they could be
ngos
they could be like you know various
kinds of things folks who want to foment
social change of some kind right
like a technological innovator who sees
a problem in the market and wants to
build a change here these people see a
problem in the law or in society and
they they want to take something that
was a one and turn it to a zero
something that was bad and turn it good
or vice versa and they get funding from
a philanthropist or they do it
themselves it's like bootstrapping and
they try to drive change in society okay
and if when you start thinking of them
as like a moral innovator just like a
tech interviewer so what is the ultimate
win of a moral innovator it's like
obama is a community organizer and then
he becomes president that's like a guy
starting a you know company in their
dorm room and becoming zuckerberg right
and when you see this you're like okay
there's actually a term that we use both
in the corporate world and in the
political world you know what that term
is it's president
okay you know like the president and ceo
of a company and the president of a
society right yep so
the president of a startup society has
aspects that are similar to the
technological innovator but they also
have aspects that are similar to the
moral innovator
and they started that moral innovation
so i've mentioned two so far like the
cancellation
proof culture right or the
carb free zone now you take the car free
zone you start iterating it okay so
first is everybody's dropped 30 pounds
there's no sugar
you're buying more and more territory
people are like whoa this is amazing and
crucially you have border control right
you have an immigration and application
process people sometimes get mad about
this i'm like look if harvard can do it
if the new york times can do it if they
can filter aggressively everybody who
steps into harvard yard or into the new
york times company slack then you have
license to it you have complete moral
license to be as ruthlessly selective as
they are right on the institutions they
care about they're highly highly highly
highly selective right so you have more
license to do that okay so you're more
licensed to be selective now by the way
being selective on entrance is different
than not letting people exit it's like
you don't let everybody into your house
but if they want to leave your house of
course you let them leave right so you
know they are different entrance and
exit
so you have selective migration in and
you're looking for people who have you
mean physical migration or is this
digital presence yeah digital and
physical basically you don't they don't
just get an account see the difference
is in the 2000s
people just wanted everybody to sign up
online right social networks were just
about quantity quantity quantity
quantity just get everybody online right
that was the right decision at that
point they were just meant to be super
viral
the thing is there's a network effect
but you know what we also have is we
have a network defect
okay
when you get to a certain scale of a
network everybody starts fighting with
each other because they weren't selected
on the basis of aligned moral values
what happens is
the network effect normally the the
whole metcalf's law at n square the more
people the more interaction assumes
those interactions are a positive sum
but you have to very carefully engineer
a network for that to be the case
something like twitter has a global
leader board which is inherently zero
sum if you're rising the leaderboard i'm
falling or vice versa so that results in
coalitional zero-sum behavior a group of
people align with each other to get to
the top of the leaderboard and knock
others down
that means that you have a network
defect because people polarize around
certain moral beliefs and the network
actually starts becoming less valuable
as it increases in scale
just like a company you're just hiring
more people is not necessarily the
optimum strategy right
so the network defect means that you in
this era you don't just want to be super
viral and grow to the moon you want to
grow to the
limit of
what makes sense
for your community to work you know and
that could be very different for
different kinds of one commandments
i'll give several other examples so the
carb free one right if you take that
further so first you've i'm gonna say
carb free obviously i should really mean
sugar-free low-carb actually balls you
may pause you for one second just to ask
a logistics question so on the physical
migration piece i'm wondering
how that would need to be formatted so
you wouldn't run a foul of
state or federal various laws exactly
right discrimination laws and i would
imagine i mean if let's just say it's a
small town you mentioned archipelago so
they could be
a distribution of islands that are very
small like private residences or or gyms
or whatever it might be but if you want
to make it a little larger
such that you could actually have a
sizable community it seems like it would
have to be
maybe privately owned such that the town
was actually considered a sole residence
or something like that that's right so
there's the entry u.s outside u.s and so
on so there's something called the
bonafide private club exemption
to the
those laws which basically says if you
are a bona fide private club with dues
paying members
then you can have restricted access to
the facilities for example 24-hour
fitness
basically has dues paying members and
not right harvard
is very selective about their admissions
right new york times is selective about
their admissions
so you you have
a genuine community online that you
start with that you're selective on
admissions and then the community goes
and buys land together right now
might there be lawsuits and stuff like
that it's possible there's lawsuits but
this is a global thing
and just the concept of a selective
online community i mean every
facebook group is selective every every
single google doc where you can add and
remove permissions is selective every
twitter group dm is selective you know
like that's actually something which is
so baked into the culture and society
that we sort of take for granted that
you have permission control over things
you know
so i do believe that that is
coming
that you're going to be able to take
those opt-in networks that people can
select into online and then materialize
them in the physical world okay now
laws are going to be different all over
the world and people will you know lose
their minds in different ways and
different aspects of this other things
you can do by the way is you could if n
if you need to just literally set quotas
and so you are hyper selective
subject to having x percent of y group
and and eight percent of z group and so
on and so forth right that's also
potentially an approach right
and like different countries actually do
things like that they just literally set
quotas rather than have to argue about
it schools do it too even though they
don't like to talk about it yeah that's
right so quotas are actually not
terribly bad necessarily because at
least it's a numerical target you have
to hit that target then subject to the
target then you're done and you've
basically shown that you're fine right
point is i do believe that if colleges
and workplaces and private clubs and so
on exist
if facebook groups and twitter groups
and signal groups if selective admission
exists of any kind right
which it does
then that group should be able to
crowdfund territory and if it can
crowdfund territory then it can erect a
border around it now crucially this is
not a typical corporation it could be
literally a co-op there could be many
structures it could be all coin holders
so it has more legitimacy
than just like a company doing it okay
so it's like a hybrid
where it is really a group of people
it's hundreds or thousands or tens of
thousands of very highly motivated
zealots and activists right who believe
in this so it doesn't feel like oh it's
just like some ceo or whatever doing it
on their own this is the thing that this
is why i also wouldn't call myself a
libertarian you know going back to that
thing about oh just go and get some land
a lot of people
will try and be like oh i'm gonna be the
prince of so and so and i'm gonna go and
put a flag in some random unclaimed
territory like like sea land is like
this or there's a spot in eastern europe
that's like this sort of spot in the
sahara desert i'm gonna be the prince of
this right
and the fundamental thing that
libertarian so they get they have half
the picture which is yes starting new
countries is good but they don't have
the other half which is the obvious
thing which is okay you and what army
right or more specifically you and what
nation
they don't have a nation they don't have
a community they don't have a people and
they start with these tangible things
like land and laws that actually come
last in the evolution okay you know what
it's like is people have lost such track
of history they don't understand the
organic formation of communities
and they just skip to the laws and the
explicit stuff as opposed to all the
implicit agreement that precedes those
laws of which those laws are simply an
encoding of those agreements and
acculturations that happened over a long
period of time right with me so far
right i am and i have another question
in a few moments so i might jump in in a
sec but please continue okay so i've
talked about a one commandment society
which was like the cancel proof one just
to extend the sugar-free one for a
second like keto kosher sugar-free
society so step one is all meals change
all restaurants change all grocery
stores change
on the one hand that's a big thing on
their hand it's focused
you're not saying again you're not
saying traffic lights change okay you're
not saying 50 other regulations
thousands of regulations that apply
you're not saying you're not trying to
change building codes you're not trying
to have self-driving cars you're focused
on one thing in that community right do
one thing really well
and you know that that one thing of
sugar-free
after people lose 30 pounds then what
happens maybe then everybody gets
equipped with a cgm continuous glucose
monitor right or you start rolling out
other quantified cell stuff to the
community that moral innovation unlocks
another moral innovation and another and
you start going from one commandment to
1.5 and you start actually building it
out now to your point earlier about how
do you know that this isn't like like
some kind of cult how do you know that
it doesn't go wrong it's checked by exit
everybody can leave at any time it's
literally got to recruit subscribers and
if you don't like it you don't subscribe
and if you do like it you keep your
subscription and if you liked it but now
don't like it you cancel and you leave
okay it's society as a service sas
the next sas okay um except
isn't that good
yeah that's good clever and that is
something where
it also does something else which is
it's 100 democracy rather than 51
democracy
51 democracy
is
what it sounds like 51 democracy is 49
dictatorship 49 of people did not vote
for this guy
at any time nowadays and for the last 30
years or something like that these
elections have been very very close and
they feel
rightfully so that they did not get
their guy in power
and they do not feel empowered they you
know and and this is being teetered like
this is not just in the u.s in lots of
countries
at any time on the order of 50 in the
country feels the election you know they
don't agree with the election right i'm
not i'm not talking about any particular
situation simply the fact that you just
keep getting 51 49 49 51
the alternative to that where it's like
the fosbury flop as we talked about the
phosphate flop of democracy
is 100 democracy where every single
person in this community has agreed to
be there and can leave at any time they
have consented and it's a consensual
society the consent of the governed is
actually the upstream thing of which
voting is only this very downstream
thing and voting can be manipulated
voting in the soviet union you know they
voted in the soviet union you you went
there and you had a ballot and it had
nothing on it if you wanted to vote for
the communist and you could write the
name on it if you wanted to vote for
non-communist and everybody would look
at you and be like
you really want to do that
the poke is in that quite a few counties
in the u.s there's also only one party
on the ballot
so it's actually not as dissimilar
right in the sense that the smoke-filled
room of the primary
is the actual election
and then the public just simply ratifies
whoever's at the top of that party's you
know selection process right so that's
the poke is that laughable communist
process that we talked about is not that
far away from
a primary or like a party selection
process that's a real election and then
people just pick their party candidate
in the general okay go
okay and go here
all right i'm warmed up so
i am
just to be clear to everybody listening
very deeply interested in this entire
conceptualization of the network state
which is why i'm asking all these
clarifying questions
yep so you mentioned
100 democracy
people have to be recruited if they
don't want to be part of the community
as a subscribing member they can leave
now one could say
well
even if we will look at the 49
ruled by dictator
effect if we want to call it that in the
united states people could leave
they could leave now taxation would
follow them unless they renounce
citizenship and so on and so forth but
they could physically leave but a lot of
those people either don't have the means
or the will
or fill in the blank to relocate so i'm
imagining you brought up el salvador
earlier it's like all right if someone
burns their bridges socially and
professionally
moves to el salvador to be part of a
cryptocentric community
and then they
they end up
i'm not saying this is the case but
they're like oh [ __ ] this is turning
into the mosquito coast and
animal farm all wrapped into one this is
a mess
they could in
theory leave but there may be any number
of factors maybe they married someone
and had kids with someone who doesn't
want to leave there are all sorts of of
attenuating factors that could influence
their ability to migrate so my question
following up on that is
what are some of the most interesting
attempts at anything related to network
state that
you could mention and the reason i bring
it up is for a while i remember in
silicon valley
there's a lot of talk of seasteading
seasteading seasteading seasteading and
people can look this up and certainly
there are experiments being run and have
been run for a long time with
intentional communities that have
on some level
let's just call them tenets of a
doctrine right or agreements or
commandments
so where would you point what are what
are some interesting things that you're
seeing
that you think are worth mentioning
one important
thing i just want to say is that in the
book i make a distinction i talk about
startup societies and network states and
i define a network state as actually one
that has
diplomatic recognition from an existing
sovereign
which is an unusual definition because
you might say wait a second
like
why does why do you care whether
florida or
you know denmark or the united nations
recognizes you
why should that matter you should be
able to just do it totally from scratch
right
and the the reason that i have that
that's that's a very high bar for
diplomatic recognition the analogy would
be bitcoin starting as a pure internet
phenomenon and then eventually
getting listed on bloomberg and
eventually eventually becoming the
sovereign currency of el salvador right
it attained diplomatic recognition but
it took like 10 years right
the reason is that that as i can get
into diplomatic recognition is actually
very important because it means the
existing it's almost like uh the crypto
fiat exchange okay
like you know the exchange between
crypto and fiat the ability to be
halfway
dollars or 95
and 5 crypto that exchange turns out to
be like a critical part of the entire
transition to crypto in the same way the
exchange or the interface between crypto
countries and fiat countries is the
diplomatic recognition of a network
okay so that portability is you know one
one dimension of it
another dimension is the one you're
talking about which is physical
migration
and
the thing is that
there's like several things i can say so
first is if somebody plans poorly you
can't be their keeper you know you can't
necessarily look out for them on
everything what you can do is you can
try to reduce the cost or the barriers
to exit
and one of the things i mentioned when i
talked about earlier i said american
anarchy on the other side of the world
what's burgeoning is the opposite of
that which i call chinese control
and the scenario that i think might
happen in china
is there's this book by roger garside
called
coup
and you know various guys george soros
is kind of hinted at this
you know there's this group the cyborg
group in the us that put out a video
about a month ago that's talking about
cyborg and has like photos of china and
how they're doing cyborg in china do you
see this video this ghost video
no but i would love a link we'll put it
in the show notes as well
so short answer is or short version is
i think it is possible
i can't say 100
but that
some kind of china coup will be
attempted against
xi jinping or the chinese communist
party
but i don't think it's gonna
so whether it's like actually u.s backed
or not i don't know but for garcia to
put out a book like this for soros to
make the comments he's has for this jay
sock to put that video out there for all
the talk about oh they're you know not a
democracy and and you know so on and
like a lot of the
same energy versus russia
it's quite possible that some kind of
china coup will be attempted i don't
think it's going to succeed for a
variety of reasons but that's like the
the thing that the chinese system is
armored against
and i think that the response to an
attempt like that
would be
an ai
okay the aii of the chinese state
ripping out
any piece of civil society
by the roots that possibly collaborated
with that
okay
and the kinds of consequences of that i
couldn't imagine but it'd be like they
could do cutoffs of physical goods as
targeted reverse physical sanctions you
know like okay we'll sell you chairs but
not these key screws that you need for
certain military things like it'd be
viewed as this insanely hostile act and
you might say well i mean this
government is smart enough that it won't
try that the established respondents
won't try that like
have you noticed nuclear brinkmanship
with russia have we have we seen you
know some of the stuff even if you agree
as i do that you know like the
ukrainians
deserve freedom and so on i don't think
that some of the stuff where it's like
being very casual about nuclear war is
smart
and i also think that the fact that
they're still poking on things like
taiwan and so on while they're in the
middle of the russia ukrainian war you
know there's very statements of being
put out on taiwan i think biden put out
some statement and pulled it back and
put out some statement
this does not show a degree of caution
on this topic my point is
i think while american anarchy is
happening or before it gets underway
chinese
control could follow a chinese crackdown
and what does that happen
what does that mean it means chinese
people can't leave the country
it's already happening where passport
issuance is like down 95 over there
they're using the qr codes that they set
up for
the you know covet stuff for internal
lockdowns there's already the
pre-existing kukau system of internal
passports they know that lots of hong
kong people want to leave
but they don't want people to leave with
their money
and a lot of chinese people now want to
leave with their money it's called run
zoo r-u-n-x-u-e okay or run philosophy
it's like basically there's three
responses you know for the upper middle
class middle class chinese liberal and
those are rat race life flat
get out or run zoo okay
so
ronzo
will the problem is there's reactivity
on everything and the more popular that
becomes the more it's going to be
portrayed as some combination
unpatriotic some combination you know
like trying to take your money and leave
after all china is done so they're
cutting off the exits in their own way
to your point right so chinese control
is on their side of the world and you
know what they're going to say is
they're going to say
look
we just stopped
this american-style anarchy and they're
going to export that surveillance state
to lots of countries and they'll say
look this is just total stability and
you will never have anarchy and you will
just be able to rule forever
because our aii will pick up every
possible form of organization against
you any possible form of dissent
and that's just total order without any
feedback signal whatsoever on power okay
whereas anarchy is the total opposite of
that right so you're going to get i feel
this world i'm seeing things tracking
towards that where you have just total
disorder over here which will be
justified by saying it's not the chinese
all-seeing eye and you'll have the
chinese all-seeing eye justified by the
fact that it's not the total disorder
here and it's like the nazism versus
communism thing except it is total
decentralization versus total
centralization and the alternative to
that is
many different examples of
recentralization
and what i mean by that is you know you
said pick el salvador pick another
country
the thing is that if you didn't like gem
and you didn't like ford and you didn't
like chrysler well you could found tesla
you could found something that actually
i mean it's very hard you have to be
alone maybe but it was possible to do so
and if software if you don't like you
know some
software company you know like you
didn't like google docs people could
found notion right even a big company
you could tackle like this yep so the
thing is that that ability to start that
startup society
even if it doesn't have the full
diplomatic recognition of a network
state
is how those options actually increase
because you mentioned oh if you don't
like the current options go to el
salvador but el salvador is fine
i'm just proud
no i didn't say that and i'm fine with
el salvador i don't have personal issues
with el salvador i'm just saying that
most of the experiments we're talking
about what i mean is of the menu yeah
the menu i'm just like it seems like the
crypto tail is wagging the dog a bit in
the same
way that the tax tail wags the dog when
people are like yeah it's great in this
place and i'm looking at them
in zoom and they're like tires on fire
in the street behind them with razor
wire around their compound and i'm just
saying what the [ __ ] are you doing man
like just save whatever you're saving
anyway that's all i'm saying yeah yeah
so that's the thing is also one of the
big things about what i'm talking about
here is it's absolutely morality first
and money second
you know they're saying missionary over
mercenary
so there's this great interview from
several years ago charlie rose
had an interview
with this historian called paul johnson
okay and he essentially points out that
the for-profit colonies in america
mostly fail but as the religious ones
that the cohesion and commitment to make
it through the brutal winters
okay
just like the religious maximalist
community has the cohesion and
commitment to make it through the brutal
crypto winters right
yeah bring it back around to where we're
talking about earlier and just like the
situation that we're potentially
entering in the u.s
it could be
like the next great depression it could
be the great stagnation or the great
stag inflation or the great inflation it
could be not something that bounces back
in a year or two years like our previous
experience but something where the
government cannot print money and cannot
fix it and it has to actually be fixed
with like genuine innovation and not
top-down control and silencing of all
descent and not anarchy and shooting
people but actually innovation that is
that could be by the way very
non-consensus the reason by the way i
bring up something like carb free right
or or sugar free rather
is
if you think about great startups
some of them are very ambitious sounding
like spacex and others sound incredibly
stupid and trivial like 140 characters
right but now today both twitter and
spacex are big companies
and a lot of startup societies will be
similar they'll either sound totally
trivial like carb free
or insanely ambitious like
fda free
right and
the thing is you don't necessarily know
which startup societies are going to
work
you just have to run the experiment and
allow people to set them up society as a
service and allow people to opt into
them and that's what a lot of this book
is about
so i want to take
one quick
sidebar and then we're going to come
back to the main thread in the very
beginning of this conversation
i asked you to
comment on the current state of the
crypto market and the india sphere and
we did not get to the india sphere yes
would you mind just taking
a few minutes not very many but just a
few minutes to share
any and all thoughts first defining what
india's fear means and then thoughts on
the india sphere
so
here's what i'll say about india i will
just give a couple of links okay because
i can talk about it verbally but sanjeev
sanyal actually
put out an economic survey of india
here i'm just going to link that here
okay
about three or four months ago
and it just has
tons of maps
and those maps show like
nighttime luminosity
the national highway network
you know the airports the water
connections
the issue is like this is obvious if
you're on the ground but
it is it is the most obvious for
somebody who knows india enough to have
visited but is not there every single
day right because if you're there every
single day it's kind of gradual it's an
improvement but it's gradual but you
don't necessarily appreciate it and if
you've never come and you have nothing
to to benchmark it against you don't see
the changes but for the intermittent
visitor it's astonishing what's happened
and what's really good about this
set of graphs is it shows it for the
whole country right so lighting highway
build-outs
airports basic infrastructure has been
dramatically improved over the last 10
years yeah tap water potable water right
potable water exactly like so the thing
is india is becoming like and 4g and all
the internet stuff if you look at this
whole thread okay
basically
the second reference i point you to is a
article called the internet country by
tigerfeathers.substance.com
okay and that is a ton of graphs in just
the digital story and showing the build
out of
you know literally like a billion people
now it's like 800 million something like
that
got onto
some of the fastest cheapest mobile
internet in the world over the last five
years and so the h1b visa doesn't even
matter anymore what matters is the tcp
visa like the labor shock this
represents the culture shock this
represents like most people haven't game
this out but the majority of english
speakers on the internet are or soon
will be india
english-speaking culture is going to be
influenced by like indian culture it's
just like this total thing that's not on
people's radars they have not priced the
sin
okay most of your followers will
probably be indian by like 2030 or
something like that right most of your
upvotes most of your
comments and stuff a very large fraction
already are
but you know it's something where it's
sort of a it's like two giant tanks of
water that are now connected by the
internet and that are like diffusing
into each other
the other thing is also during that
process
see for many years
indians had you know like uh like my
parents generation
because they grew up in india they came
over with accents and and so and so they
had portable technical skills in
engineering or medicine or something
like that
but they weren't really culturally
fluent you know they knew how to operate
in india but not really in the us
or in the globe the internet
dramatically changes that because all
those kids in india
understand
instagram memes
and tik tok and all that stuff they are
internet native right they've learned it
as a second language and maybe if they
speak they might have an accent but even
that it's like you know you're getting
ai audio generation and so on and so
forth right
so the cultural fluency
is there in a way that was absolutely
not there so they won't be like
foreigners you know you won't know that
they're indian in a thread that's a huge
difference that many people has not been
culturally acclimatized that quickly
ever before okay so that's like
on the internet component i don't think
people have thought about
and then the government component
you know look there's pros and cons of
any government and in many ways i think
india's government is like
two steps forward one step back there's
a saying india disappoints both the
india disappoints both the optimists and
the pessimists right
that's a good one right it's not mine
but somebody came up with this pretty
good it is good yeah
so this link that i just pasted in
if you just go and you read the india
budget government document okay
and just to pause to tell people that
i'll put all of these links in the show
notes at tim.blog
podcast so you'll be able to find all
these very easily please please continue
yes so it's got
digital universities drone farms
telemedicine
open source like
it is an extremely tech savvy future
forward
thing right like it's it's insane how
how smart it is right
just don't take my word for it read it
yourself okay and then as contrast okay
go and read mike solana's article mike
salon is a great guy smart guy from
founders fund he's got a subset called
pirate wires his article he wrote called
trillion dollar paint job from
last year august 11 2021 yeah
piratewires.com
yeah piratewise.com and the article is
called trillion dollar paint job and
what he pointed out about six months
before that set of tweets about nine
months ago
is
this gigantic multi-billion dollar
budget is
like
what are they building right the only
thing they were doing was banning
cryptocurrency he was like the the one
exciting thing
in the entire
bill were the charging stations for
electric vehicles right he's like
charging stations for electric vehicles
account for a tiny fraction of
expenditure and appear in almost every
recap of the bill why such relentless
focus from the media on so minor and
element of our bold new infrastructure
strategy i think we're all desperate for
a sense of forward motion right
the charging stations at least represent
something new a physical change that
alters the world for the better beyond
that it's not at all clear but our
political leaders are trying to build i
do however have a sense of what they're
trying to destroy
bingo right
essentially the east coast establishment
the u.s establishment
basically hates these tech interlopers
and rather than figure out how to ever
have everybody take a cut or whatever
and level up together
has decided to try to fight it which is
now resulting in i think going to be
about like some of it actually worked
where they managed to wokify and capture
google and these big companies it's
really bad because it means that they
are going to be turned into surveillance
machines are already you know like have
you seen the google
ai thing that's trying to say landlord
is bad language in your google doc do
you see that
no but happy to link to it for people
yeah yeah so it's like google docs
landlord
suggest
thing i mean the thing is look it's
google right there's this apocryphal
story which i believe is not actually
true but it's like the reason that
spanish people speak spanish with a lisp
is because supposedly the king spoke
with the lisp and wanted people to do
that right that mythical story google
has literally billions of users it has
if it decides to use it the power to
shape language and speech and thought
with its suggests with its autocompletes
with things like this right yeah and
so
that power
in like centralized hands
is an insane thing it's almost
impossible to because undetectable you
kind of think of yourself as paranoid
this is an explicit example where the
suggest is explicit right yeah the the
sanitizing of cognition yeah it's wild
so that will be a way that the social
war is going to be fought where google
and things like that are weaponized
against the population which is why we
need these web3 and other services so
that you can get off of google and get
off of you know amazon and get off of
these bookified things anyway coming
back up rather than trying to work with
tech they wanted to fight it kill it
wokify it anti-trust it capture it
they've been partially successful in
that but they've also done is they have
turned the latest generation of tech
founders very much against the u.s
establishment all the guys who are
running companies that are worth less
than 100 billion
are basically
pro bitcoin and less aligned with the us
carbon i should say all but let's say i
don't know if it's
if they managed to capture google they
did so
at the cost of
splitting alienating and polarizing a
generation of up-and-coming founders not
just in the us but very importantly
outside tech has been pushed outside of
the u.s and the us is no longer like
the majority of tech most tech actually
happens outside the us so the whole
concept that's very america-centric that
it's all in silicon valley silicon
valley have you heard the term meta nym
nope but i'm guess
it's like an antonym or a or a synonym
but it's a meta nym so it's a word that
what is like an umbrella term that
captures a bunch of things so a metanum
is when you use a place to stand in for
a concept right
so like
hollywood is movies and silicon valley
is tech and so on right i see and i had
this tweet which was deprecate metonyms
via decentralizing technology right so
finance is not wall street advertising
is not madison avenue film is not
hollywood education is not the ivy
league space isn't nasa cars are not
detroit and technology is not silicon
valley as obsolete is broadway right
and the thing is you can already see
some of those things happening like cars
are not detroit it's tesla right and
space isn't nasa it's spacex right
and you know film you know it's starting
to move away from hollywood as well
advertising's already not madison avenue
it's arguably moved away all quite a bit
but once you see that you're like and
you apply the totem you're like oh all
of those
things were like points in the u.s which
dominated certain industries and all
them are getting decentralized by
technology at the same time anyway
coming back up so
with the india thing a there's sanjeev
sanyol's survey
economic survey of india which shows all
the maps b there's tiger feathers which
surveys on the digital build up
c there is this link to the
indian governments like their spending
bill it's not just spending bill is
their budget basically and then d the
comparison of that to the american
budget of this i think the same fiscal
year or plus minus one
and an enormous gap
absolutely enormous gap where technology
is seen as a tool to make india and
indians more prosperous across the
political spectrum and it's basically
like seen as opposite in the u.s
with i understand why it's because the
rise of technology correlated with the
relative fall
of american living standards
globally relative to the rest but it
didn't have to be like that in my view
right with better leadership it didn't
have to be like that
so
that's a quick summary on india
and i think hopefully that's enough data
that's great that's great and we will
link to all these things in the show
notes so biology at biology s on twitter
oh wait can i say one more thing let me
say one more thing you can well you
absolutely have to also mention where
people can find the network state how to
start a new country sure yes you can say
another thing i will say one thing and
i'll say that last thing okay so the one
thing i was going to say is going back
to that god state network framework
i am
i'm bullish on indians
and
modestly bullish on india that is to say
the indian state
i'm like very modestly in favor or very
modestly bullish on but the indian
network
of the global diasporic indians
connected to certainly many indians
within the indian
territory but not necessarily the indian
government per se or indian
establishment even the indian network
i'm very bullish on and actually
one of the dark horse projections i have
in the book for the future is that by
if in
by 1945 the 20th century was the usa
versus the ussr right the americans
versus the russians you know the two
guys who were on the edges who everybody
could see growing they had huge
populations in the 1800s but they were
kind of on the periphery europe just
slugged it out between themselves and
eventually
in that title fight you know it was it
was the americans versus the russians
i kind of think that by 2040 or 2050
maybe sooner or maybe later
that there's a chance that this century
is
the chinese state versus the indian
network
so the centralized sinic state versus
the dharmic decentralized global network
right i kind of think that's how things
line up and the the real
sort of you have to sort of squint to
see this as an edge case but in the same
of the uk sort of handed the torch to
the us which is an english-speaking
kind of thing
in some ways the us i think may hand the
torch because the global
english-speaking internet is going to
become india
and in so far as the u.s as a country
doesn't exist and you have all these
startup societies and so on
that decentralized english-speaking
internet will have very strong indian
representation around the world and the
opposite of it will be like the chinese
control
right now i know that's very speculative
and i'm connecting a bunch of dots and
so on
and that's not at all like you know one
very important thing here is
it's probably will come out on the
fourth of july none of what i'm saying
or i'm thinking in the book i would not
call any of it like anti-american any
more than i'd say then washington was
anti-british or that
herzl
or ben gurion was anti-british or lee
kuan yew is anti-british or even the
indian independence woman was
anti-british they were critical of the
british for a time but afterwards after
a little bit of distance america
india israel singapore all have good
relations with britain they're basically
they're post-british they weren't
anti-british right
and
the key question is rather than be like
pro-american anti-like if this
won't last if this current pax americana
won't last what does post-american look
like without any hostility really
towards the old thing indeed with
gratitude towards everything it
contributed but recognizing that not
everything can endure and people realize
that the currency won't endure but
perhaps the state won't endure either
and we need to
think about positive new models for the
future that do not involve condemning
the past i mean any more than we we
don't condemn britain all the time we're
basically grateful towards it or
positively inclined towards it but we've
we're moving along another axis right so
rather than be pro or anti-british
rather than define it as post british
right on pro ranch american what does
post-american look like and prepare for
that and you know what maybe i'm
completely wrong maybe maybe all the
base raiders are right maybe everything
just continues and so on but if you
think that we might want to actually try
to build an alternative and the same
with a a founder or an activist doesn't
simply let things happen but take things
into their own hands i think i've got a
model for that a position model putting
it out there that's at
thenetworkstate.com you can also read it
at 1729.com
and that's like an online book and so on
so by the time this
podcast goes out you'll that'll probably
be live
all right so one more time what were the
urls just so people catch them
so go to one seven
nine
and you can read the book online
download the pdf and you can click and
if you want to buy it on amazon um so
it's free to read online and you can
check it out
oh and also subscribe because we're
going to be releasing more chapters and
so on i know that normally an app is
supposed to be dynamic and a book is
supposed to be static but i think of
this as a book app because you put
something out into the world and people
are going to react and there's going to
be incomplete things or things i want to
say differently and so on and so forth
and so i'll keep editing it and i'll
keep sending out new stuff so you can
subscribe and get all that for free if
any of this interested
1729.com and we talked about the origin
story of that separately so we won't get
into it right now yes it's basically the
publisher of the book
[Music]
biology very nice to see you again and
for those who aren't watching the video
you know these are two contrasts in
style you've got sort of my floral
pattern full of all sorts of
embellishments that i need to keep my
mood stabilized to get even a modicum of
anything done and then you've got
biology in his spartan what looks like
tech war room preparing for the future
with no golden fetters no no dross
i do have i have a plant here it's just
out of frame
and i have
it's like you know the canadian
girlfriend right
my plant that's just out of frame right
did you know the reference
i don't i like it even though i don't
understand it it's basically like oh i
have a girlfriend but she's in canada
you know yeah that's that's balogi's
plant
yeah a cactus that needs water once
every 70 years yes exactly that's
actually right this is a symbol of
resilience that's right it is highly
resilient and i have my white board on
the back for my math so
oh man well biology uh i really
appreciate you taking the time i'm
excited for you i'm excited for people
to read the network state how to start a
new country you can find it on 1729.com
check it out biology of course you can
find on twitter
he is insightful and prolific at biology
s we will link to everything we
mentioned in the show notes at tim dot
blog slash podcast
and
thank you biology always fun to see you
thank you sir i appreciate the time all
right thank you very much and everybody
listening be safe be kind and thanks for
tuning in
you